this is Jocko podcasts number 98 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willing good
evening echo good evening they asked us
to take off our head scarves then loosen
any buttons to reveal our chests that
courtyard became the marketplace where
Isis men came and chose girls they liked
though they first sent all the older
women to another place and the women
with babies and other children to
another place we do not know the
whereabouts of these women and that
includes my mother and my sisters I had
my period that night but no matter how
much I told him I have my period he did
not believe me he ordered me to strip
naked in his room then he stuck his
finger in my vagina and saw that I was
indeed bleeding only then did he believe
but that did not mean he left me alone
instead he put the air conditioner on a
really high volume said that I am to sit
still in my nudity the whole night and
he molested me throughout the night by
the time morning arrived I was frozen
both physically and psychologically
nothing mattered after that point I
didn't know I had not seen the worst of
it yet he would put on horrible sexual
movies and would do all kinds of things
to me they all had long hair and long
beards but the worst of all is their
smell I've never smelled such awful
smell in my life they do not bathe they
feel more like beasts than human only
Yazidi women are taken as slaves
Hsieh women they burn alive we saw one
she a woman burned alive in front of us
Christian women they leave on the
condition that their family must pay a
fee for Isis for being Christian in Isis
tour territories and Sunni women are
left alone as long as they follow Isis
orders if they don't they are whipped
and tortured some of them are the wives
of our captors some of the wives were as
helpless as we were and some were very
mean women who encouraged their men to
rape us as long as a girl has some
breasts she's considered a woman and
that entitles them to rape her some
girls are as young as 10 and 11 years
old I have no past and no future at the
moment I am stuck in my anger and pain
at what Isis did to my family my
community and myself I have a new
behavior that I can't stop including
washing my mouth over and over again
there are nights I wake up more than one
time to wash my mouth as I remember what
they did to me and how they forced
themselves on me I am a dead person now
I have no life I only hope that my
mother comes back from capture so my
life can resume
so those are excerpts from an article
that was in the New York Times by zainab
Salvi and the quotes are from Leila
which is a pseudonym who was a Yazidi
woman captured by Isis and obviously
kept as a slave and she eventually
escaped and gave that interview in a
camp in Erbil which is in northern Iraq
which at the time was an Iraqi
government controlled City and I would
say this if you think that evil does not
exist in the world you are wrong it does
and it's not just individuals scattered
around these are groups of supposed
human beings that are systematically
implementing heinous and evil acts on
totally innocent people and I have
obviously talked about evil before on
this podcast 20 years ago during the
genocide in Rwanda 50 years ago in
Vietnam during the meal I massacre 75
years ago in Nazi Germany 80 years ago
in Nanking under the Imperial Japanese
Army and those things are in the past
but it is important to remember that
evil is still happening now and I know
that it is hard for us to see that
especially here in America in this
unbelievably well-protected bubble that
we live in a bubble that is provided and
protected by young and brave men and
women
who volunteer to go out and hold the
line but the evil is out there it always
is
and tonight we have a guest on the
podcast that I think has a very clear
understanding of evil of where it comes
from and how it manifests itself in the
world and he also has an incredible
understanding of the good and what we as
people can do to live our lives better
for ourselves for families for our
communities and for the world
his name is dr. Jordan B Peterson and
I'm not exactly sure when I heard dr.
Peterson for the first time but as I dug
into the content online what really
struck me was that what he was saying
and he was an academic an unbelievably
smart unbelievably well-read person and
yet when he said things they aligned
almost perfectly with things that I
believed and things that I have learned
in my life and so here we were these two
radically different people from
different backgrounds one
highly-educated college professor the
other a military veteran and a certified
knuckle dragger
and yet our thoughts were very aligned
and the way that I would hear him tie
history and fought around human
psychological evolution and to the
social structure and to societal
structure and the way he laid out the
maps of meaning behind the way we think
it was very useful
and it's helped me realize that the way
I feel in my gut my instincts about
people and about the world they're there
for a reason
it isn't random there is some reason
behind the way that I think and the way
that we think so
Jordan thank you for coming on the show
very glad to be here that's a that's
quite the beginning yeah I think like I
said it's very easy for people to lose
track of the fact that while you're
sitting in an air-conditioned space
somewhere thinking about your next
Netflix movie that you're going to watch
there's there are people that are in the
most horrible and heinous situations
that are being put on them by other
human beings and it doesn't really stop
yeah well it's a hard thing for people
to to contemplate I mean there's two
elements to life that are hard to
contemplate I mean one is that the
suffering that's attendant on life
fundamentally and then the other is the
malevolence of people and we're not in
the modern world we don't really think
about those as fundamental realities in
some sense you know because we we tend
to think about material situations as
fundamental realities but the
metaphysical realities the ethical
realities are more real and it's
necessary to know that in order orient
yourself properly in life like you know
I never really took the idea of good
seriously
transcendent good let's say our ultimate
good until I convinced myself of the
existence of well if it wasn't altima
deiville it was sufficiently ultimate
for me you know because I immersed
myself in the study of the Nazi
Holocaust and and of what happened in
Nanking and what happened with unit 731
which is the most horrifying that's the
most horrifying material I've ever read
which is really saying something because
there's plenty of horrifying material to
read and and what happened in the Soviet
Union and what happened in Mao's China
which
you know so few people know about now
and I guess what I found most striking
especially with regards to what happened
in the in the Soviet Union was well and
in Germany for that matter was that
there were a number of people who were
writing about it like Viktor Frankl a
psychiatrist who wrote man's search for
meaning and also Alexander Solzhenitsyn
who wrote the Gulag Archipelago which
should be required reading for every I
think for every American citizen that
there was some integral relationship
between the moral failings of
individuals and catastrophic moral
failings of the state and that that was
directly causally related you know so
Solzhenitsyn made a great case in with
regards to the analysis of the Marxist
catastrophes in the Soviet Union that
they were tied integrally not only to do
that dogma but also to the willingness
of the typical citizen to swallow
endless lies and and act them out and he
included himself in that in that set of
of deceitful people let's say and it was
really struck me that because those
writings are so profound Victor
Frankel's another good example you can't
really read that without it really
punching you you know it really struck
me that it really struck me that it was
possible that there was some direct
integral relationship between the
individual moral choices that people
made in their day-to-day lives and the
broad scale social movements that
happened around them and I think I've
come to believe that that's the case and
well certainly the story that you read
the person who was written about the
rapist was making all sorts of
individual choices right and you know he
might have been convincing himself that
he was on some kind of holy mission and
but I guess that would be in part so
that he could stand look again at
himself in the mirror in the morning
without running away screaming if he saw
what was really there so one of the
things in Franco that kind of in a man
search for meaning that definitely two
two points that really
hit me hard when I was reading it was
one as I didn't understand the extent to
which the Kappos which were the Jewish
prisoners that got taken on board to
help and would would get special
treatment at number one I didn't realize
the extent to which they were in
existence I knew that I knew what they
were but I realized that they were they
were as aggressive as they were and the
other thing that hit me is is the the
paragraph or the lines where he's saying
that the best of us didn't make it out
and that if you were going to live you
had to do things that you wouldn't want
to maybe do and maybe if you were a
better person maybe you wouldn't do him
and to me that was harsh I mean this was
his admitting that that if you wanted to
survive as a person in that situation
you might have to take someone's piece
of bread you might have to move a number
on a list to get someone else sent down
to the down to the execution area a day
earlier than you and that happens to
postpone your execution long enough that
you can make another move and that's a
scary thing you know you saw the same
thing with Solzhenitsyn's description of
the ghoul eggs because they were running
in large part by the inmates but I think
that that's a really good metaphor for
totalitarian states in general you know
because we like to think that a
totalitarian state is made up of
innocent oppressed individuals who are
under the thumb of a an evil tyrant and
that all of the catastrophes are
cascading from the top down but I don't
think that that's true I think that it's
more like a holographic structure where
the tyranny exists at every single level
so it exists psychologically and it
exists within the family and it exists
within the mid-level organizations and
so well you know in eastern Germany for
example one out of every three people
was a government informer so what that
meant is if you had a family of six
people that two of them you couldn't
trust and you can't you can't just say
that that's a consequence of the
top-down structure a tyranny is
something that exists everywhere
simultaneously once it once it gets a
grip and it's easy for people to say
things like well I was just following
orders and
you know I'm not I'm not trying to put
myself in a position where I'm claiming
that if I was in that position I
wouldn't have followed orders in the
same way I mean god only knows till you
get there right that's for sure but but
what that did to me was focus my
attention more and more on on the
necessity of individual responsibility I
thought if it was individuals in the
final analysis who were responsible for
the great evils of the 20th century
which i think is a reasonable way of of
conceptualizing it then it might be
individuals who could be responsible for
whatever good there might be in mankind
that could help us avoid those
situations in the future and I thought
of that as a alternative in some sense
to nihilistic disbelief and ideological
possession you know because if your
group identity is too tight then you
start acting like they like they well
like like a like a cog in a mob that's a
very bad thing but then if your group
identity disappears completely well then
you're left alone and bereft and so
those are bad alternatives right you
sort of damned if you do and damned if
you don't innit it was it was very
difficult to understand that there might
be a third path between those two I
couldn't see the the existence of
anything because people need belief
systems in order to exist right to
maintain psychological stability and to
main so maintain sociological stability
as well but then if the beliefs get too
rigid and they turn into the raging
totalitarian mob so maybe you let that
go because you don't want to play that
game but then you dissolve because you
have no identity that's not that's not
acceptable either when I first laid that
out that clearly it was really hard on
me because I couldn't see a third path
to that but then I started to realize
and and this was a consequence of
reading the sorts of things that we
already talked about but also of
starting to understand the underlying
structure of mythology and what the
heroic path meant essentially and that
meant adoption of supreme moral
responsibility as an individual now
there's there's this there's this idea
in the New Testament which is a really
interesting idea you know it's it's one
of these bottomless ideas and I mean
that literally
the
you could study it forever and never get
to the bottom of it and the idea is that
Christ is the person who takes the sins
of mankind on himself and there's
something redemptive about that and
that's actually a really dark idea
because what it means as far as I can
tell what it means at least what it
means psychologically is that when you
read these terrible things you have to
understand that you're reading about you
if you don't understand that you're
reading about you then you don't
actually understand the stories you know
because you you put yourself in the
position where you're automatically the
good person who would never do anything
like that and then these other people
are well they're Devils in some sense
right and it's very easy for people to
make that division but it's a horrific
realization when you think that that
devil that you see outside is the same
thing that's inside and that you don't
know until you're put in a situation
like that what you might do and then
it's even worse because if you look at
the historical evidence you know it's it
was ordinary people in some sense that
produced the catastrophes of Nazi
Germany and the Soviet Union and Maoist
China I mean they might not have
originated it but they certainly had the
option to say no at different parts of
different steps along the way and they
didn't you know and these things do
happen one horrible thing at a time
there's this great book called ordinary
men which which describes the descent of
a German police force from ordinary
burgeois middle-class men essentially
just ordinary policemen who actually
were raised before the Hitler Youth they
weren't indoctrinated you know as young
people and they were they were brought
into Poland to sort of mop up after the
Germans had walked through and it
describes how they descended into the
sort of people who would take naked
women out naked pregnant women out into
the middle of fields and shoot them in
the back of the head and what's
horrifying about the book is that the
author browning details the stages by
which this occurred and it's it's all
for example the commander of this unit
told the men that they were going to
have to do terrible things but that they
go home if they wanted to and then you
think well there's a there's an out but
but then if you really think about it
you think well there are a tight tightly
knit quasi military organization and one
of the natural thoughts under that
circumstance would be well I'm not going
to leave my comrades to do all the dirty
work that would just be a matter of
cowardice and so you can see that you
know that there's an ethical requirement
that would keep you there to begin with
and then they were well you're you're
doing what you just said
which is taking the burden of this
sinful activity on yourself if you let
everyone else do it then you're not
you're not acting heroic well right and
and and so it was easy for the men to
get entrapped into that and then you
know the requirements for their horrific
action kept ramping up and like each
time they accepted the requirement of
doing one horrific thing the probability
that they would accept the next
requirement increased and what is also
really interesting about that book huh
ordinary men is that it's not like these
men didn't suffer like they were
suffering terribly they were physically
ill they were vomiting they were they
were tearing themselves apart
psychologically you know but they didn't
quit so that's a that's a great book
because if you want to know how you walk
down the how you how you can be enticed
to walk down a terrible path that's the
book to read and it's very frightening
because if you read it properly then you
know you have to read it again as I said
as if you're one of the people to whom
this is happening and not the victim but
the oppressor you know and I mean you
can also read it as the victim that's
fair enough but but it's ordinary people
who participate in these things and
that's a very very terrifying thought we
actually covered that book on this
podcast both oh yeah yeah both Viktor
Frankl and and ordinary man huh yeah
it's interesting because I as I as I you
know I've watched all your stuff read
and one of the things that I was
thinking about is you know you talk
about where the the hero comes from
where this idea comes from and how we
ended up looking at these types of
people as they're good and it happens
over ages and ages and generations and
generations of saying oh that's a good
and that's a good quality and there's
these 10 people that are all considered
good people and they all have this
couple qualities in common so those are
good qualities and eventually that
becomes elevated to the point where we
say that's a hero and when I was
thinking of so that so that's what
happens and now we all have this
elevated thing to look at and say that's
something we could aspire to that's
where we want to go that's where we want
to be we want to we want to help and we
want to support we want to make
sacrifices for the tribe how do we end
up or who ends up saying I see something
evil and I'm gonna follow in that
direction well I think that that the
story of Cain and Abel is a really very
tightly constructed representation of
that process because I mean it's it's a
very strange story because well for a
variety of reasons first of all it's
very ancient
second of all it's the first story about
human beings mythologically speaking
with in the judeo-christian canon let's
say because Adam and Eve aren't real
people right because they are formed by
God Cain and Abel are the first people
and they're a pair of hostile brothers
and so the first thing that says is that
sibling tension within families is a
universal truth and that can get
murderous and if you don't know that and
you can't see that then you're not
watching your children carefully enough
so because what siblings can torment
each other to to a great degree and it's
something that you should strive
diligently to observe and to quell but
then there's this I the next part of it
that's so interesting is the idea of
sacrifices is introduced and that it
took me a long time to understand what
sacrifice meant because on the surface
of it especially the way it's acted out
like burnt offerings and that sort of
thing it just seems like well it seems
so archaic and and distant from us that
it's not really comprehensible but
partly from reading Jean Piaget I
started and Nietzsche for that matter I
started to understand that people often
acted out conceptions before they
understood what they meant you know and
we act out a lot of things we don't
understand because we're much more
complex than we can represent so we're
always acting out things we don't
understand but
so there's this idea and Cain and Abel
that you have to make sacrifices in
order to stay on the good side of God
and so I thought about that
practically say not so much
metaphysically but practically and
realized that that was equivalent to the
discovery of time of the future because
we do we do act in it and this is a
peculiar discovery of human beings may
be a consequence of our expanded
intelligences that we're actually aware
of the future and we actually treat the
future as if it's something that you can
bargain with now partly it's because the
future is other people and they remember
your reputation they remember your past
actions and if you do someone a favor
then that favor is in some sense stored
up in the future so you can think about
the future as a place of judgment about
your moral actions and it's not that far
from now to imagining a God who's
keeping track of that or who even is
that but in any case the idea of
sacrifice emerges in the story of Cain
and Abel and Cain and Abel both make
sacrifices to God in order to stay on
his good side let's say and what a
sacrifice means is that you give up
something of value in the present so
that you can be so that you can improve
the future and you know that's no
different from what we call discipline
it's exactly the same thing
it's just that concretely acted out
version of that and so you know the idea
basically was that well God was in the
transcendent heavens and and the first
question would be well why is that and
it's like well if you go out in I'm
really dark night and look up at the sky
you have a sense of what's beyond you
what what's transcendent what's infinite
and and so to associate that with the
highest values is a reasonable
association right from from a say from
an emotional point of view so it's not
particularly primitive it's a smart
metaphor or it's a smart intuition that
and it's above you and you know we tend
to think of when you're moving towards
an ideal that you're moving up that
you're moving above you're moving to the
mountaintop right you're going up not
down and so it all sits within that same
framework and that's partly because when
you go up like on a mountain you can see
for long distances right so those all
those things
tangle together so anyways so the idea
is that you have to give up something of
value now so you so that you make the
future better and sometimes it's even
something you love now and now that's a
good example too because often the
things that stop us from moving forward
are our attachments to things that we
should no longer be attached to right
and in fact you can almost make that
definitional if you're not moving
forward in your life there's a high
probability that you have some idea or
some mode of action or some habit that
you're so in love with that you won't
let go of it so all right so Kanan ate
Cain and Abel make sacrifices and
there's kind of a hint in this story
that it's just a hint that came
sacrifices they're sort of second-rate
but in any case its ambivalent a but but
Abel he just does wonderfully well and
everything works out for him and
everyone knows people like that you know
and so God accepts his sacrifices but
for some reason he rejects Cain's and
maybe it's the arbitrariness of God or
maybe it's because Cain's heart isn't in
the right place when he's making his
sacrifices which is more likely and so
Cain goes and has a chat with God and he
says basically what he says is something
like how in the world can you possibly
justify this universe that you created
you look at me and I'm breaking myself
in half trying to adapt and to make
things right and it's not working and
then there's this Abel character and
things come easy to him and everything
is flourishing for him and so like what
the hell and if you don't understand
that question then you're not thinking
because it's very very frequently the
case when a serious catastrophe besets
you in life that you essentially ask
exactly that question what's the meaning
of life what's the purpose of the world
how come they're suffering and it's easy
to become resentful and vengeful as a
consequence of that and so you got to
think about what state of mind having
your sacrifice is rejected puts you in
especially when you see someone who's
successful because that's where the
jealousy and and resentment starts to
starts to what fester is pro
the right word and so God says to Cain
exactly what he doesn't want to hear
which is well yeah okay but you have
made lots of mistakes in your life so he
basically says sin is at your door like
a predatory and sexually aroused animal
and you've invited it into your house to
have its way with you and produce
something creative as a consequence so
you use a sexual metaphor you know and
so that you've willingly gone down the
negative path and you've allowed that to
enter into you and and to operate in a
creative manner and you've spun off all
these terrible thoughts and and this
justification for not acting properly
and that's why things aren't going well
for you and so don't lay that at my feet
which is the most brutal possible
message he could have got and so then he
leaves the presence of God let's say and
it says in the story that his
countenance fell which meant he was
basically enraged and so what does he do
he goes out and kills Abel and then
that's that's a very fascinating idea
because Abel is his ideal so it kills
his ideal and when you kill your ideal
you're lost and then he does that to
take revenge on Abel but also to take
revenge on God which i think is
extremely interesting and and a deep
deep idea like these kids who shoot up
high schools for example you cannot
understand what they're doing unless you
understand this story of Cain and Abel
you cannot understand what possesses
them until you can understand that
someone even someone who doesn't believe
it doesn't matter it's the psychological
state of mind that matters is they're
out for revenge on being itself and
that's why they produce as much mayhem
as possible in the shortest period of
time that's why they sacrifice in
innocent people because it's much more
vengeful and and demonstrative to kill
innocent people than to kill guilty
people right because it's a worse sin so
to speak and then they killed themselves
and they killed themselves as a final
demonstration of their belief in the in
nihilism and the horror of existence
because you might say well why don't
they just kill themselves first and save
everyone the trouble you know and
there's narcissism in that too because
they know their names
to be splashed across the page that's
their notoriety instead of their
accomplishment and of course the media
is unbelievably complicit in that but
well so when you're talking about
motivation for evil then you have to
understand what it is that's driving it
and it is a deep resentment about the
structure of being for being what
saturated with suffering but also for
rejecting your rejecting your sacrifices
and not you know that produces the
bitterness of failure and I'll start
with this one of the things that's
really interesting about the old
testament is that and the Jews in the
Old Testament is that they don't take
the path of cain every time their
walloped by god which is like fairly
frequently they say we must have done
something wrong and we have to set
ourself right and that's a an
unbelievably heroic attitude because
that's the alternative cursing fate it's
like you take the responsibility for
failure unto yourself and you think well
if I was just maybe if I just had my act
together a little bit more if I took
advantage of every opportunity that was
put in front of me if I wasn't resentful
and bitter then I could have done
something that would have tilted the
situation in a different direction and
like that's almost inevitably true
well it's interesting and again this is
kind of where when I would hear you say
things like that so as you know I wrote
a book called extreme ownership that the
opening chapter of the book is a
horrible situation with a fratricide
happens on the battlefield so friendly
forces killing friendly forces some of
those forces being mine and you know
it's all these people I could blame and
all these little incidents that happen
that I could have said well you know we
had this radio cryptographic change that
happened in the middle of operation and
and it had people weren't able to talk
to each other and we had these Iraqis
that we didn't speak English we had
these units that we hadn't worked with
before and they did things that we
didn't expect and there's plenty of
blame to go around and and essentially I
said hey you know whose fault this is
this is my fault I'm the commander and
so when I hear you say things like that
it strikes me that you uncovered this
through your
study of history and and philosophy and
religion and I learned it you know as
like I said a certified knuckle dragger
out on the battlefield that realized you
know if you're gonna exist as a leader
and as a human then you need to take
responsibility for what happens around
you and that's if you have to take well
the religious notion in some sense is
that you have to take ultimate
responsibility and that in some sense
the things that happen around you I mean
this is Dostoevsky I think said
something like every man is responsible
for everything that happens to him and
everything that happens to everyone else
and that's you know that that's that's
it's a crazy statement right it's a
crazy statement and he was a pretty
extreme person in many many ways but
there's a level at which that's
metaphysically true you know because
what happens is that it's you its
failure to act often that's the most
catastrophic you know I mean it's it's
it's to not do the right thing when the
when the situation presents itself and
it's very specific you know you're
constantly in situations where you could
do the right thing if you were willing
to take a risk that's actually of
relatively moderate size and you know
that you could take the risk and you
know that you should take the risk and
you don't and that happens to people all
the time and then what happens is the
thing that they didn't oppose grows a
little bit and they shrink a little bit
and that starts a looppay and so and you
say well how do you take responsibility
for the world and the answer is well you
also have to do it with a certain degree
of humility because what do you know you
know and and and this is part of the
reason that I'm so opposed to the
activist culture on college campuses you
don't teach eighteen year olds to go and
demonstrate about capitalism you know
because they don't know anything and
they have problems in their own life
that need to be solved that are local
and and the local problems aren't
trivial you know they're not disciplined
they're there they're not looking at the
world in a straight way they're not
taking responsibility for themselves or
for their action
their sexual actions among others
they're not taking responsibility for
their family they're not looking at how
they could contribute to the community
they don't understand the fact that they
don't know anything and so they should
be taught to start locally and to put
things together that they could put
together you know to make their bed and
to clean up the room and to attend their
classes with regularity if they're going
to university because that's part of the
implicit contract and to straighten up
the things around them that are actually
within their power to straighten up and
then what happens is that if you do that
let's say religiously which I suppose
would be the same as in a disciplined
manner that your realm of influence
starts to grow but it grows in a
positive way just like you can go you
can take you can end up and he'll one
step at a time and that's
extraordinarily well documented you can
end up at the opposite place of that one
step at a time but it's also that same
gradual process you don't get to leap
from being a seventeen-year-old knothead
who doesn't know anything and who isn't
disciplined to the critic of
judeo-christian society you just don't
know enough to do that especially when
you can look at your own life and think
about how many things that you're doing
that you know are wrong that you could
fix that you aren't fixing and that's
the crucial thing it's it's this isn't
this this mode of thinking isn't asking
people to stretch themselves beyond what
they're capable of it's just asking them
to stretch themselves to the point that
they are capable of and seeing what
happens and that works it works I've had
many people write me over the last year
and this is a great thing really it's a
great thing who said that they stopped
started to tell the truth or at least
not to lie because who can tell the
truth right but at least you can not lie
and that they started to put things in
order around them that they could put an
order and that you know the positive
things just started to happen like mad
and they're not nihilistic and they've
got a purpose in their life and so you
know thank God for that and it does work
I was trying to think of how to stop the
loop of my sacrifices have been rejected
and and the way that you stopped that
loop is instead of saying the
my sacrifices were rejected so my hard
work my effort my everything that I'm
doing to try and move forward it's not
working and and if you want to go
towards hell you keep saying well it's
it's not working but it's but it's
because of everyone else it's they're
rejecting me they're not accepting what
I've done whereas if you say to yourself
oh it didn't work okay it's my fault
what can I do better and that's how you
start moving in the other direction
which is yeah well at least you have
control and you know you don't even
necessarily have to think it's your
fault although that's that's a
reasonable way of looking at it you
could you could minimally just accept
the fact that it's your responsibility
you're stuck with it and you could
actually change it and once you know to
that if you're failing repeatedly then
there's probably something wrong it's
possible that there's something wrong
with the way that you're conceptualizing
the world because you have a choice
right if if you keep making sacrifices
and they don't work there's a binary
choice and one is well there's something
wrong with the structure of reality and
the other is there's something wrong
with your approach and so then you might
say well let's take the first idea
there's something wrong with the
structure of reality it's like you're
really gonna say that are you you're
really going to come out and say I know
enough to judge the nature of being and
and then the alternative is also quite
frightening because then you know you
it's you that's making the mistakes and
you might be wrong at a really deep
level and that might mean that a lot of
you has to burn off and be transformed
maybe even things about yourself that
you think are admirable and that you
like because your position you know your
your self conceptualization is so warped
and wrong and that's really daunting but
you know when people set themselves up
as the judge of being I mean I've
written about this a fair bit in my new
book which is called 12 rules for life
when people set themselves up as the
judge of being then they take on what
can only be described as a kind of
satanic arrogance because they've
actually taken to themselves the moral
right to criticize the structure of
existence itself it's like you better be
careful when you do something like that
because you're setting yourself up as
the judge of being the
Columbine kids did that like if you read
what they wrote it's that's exactly what
happened and that's exactly what they
say is that you know I've taken onto
myself the task of the judge of being
and found it wanting and so I'm going to
cause as much mayhem as I possibly can
before I you know before I depart and
that's a very common story among people
who do that sort of thing it's and it's
so interesting because every time
something like that happens people go
well we don't understand it's like no
you won't understand because they write
about what they're doing they tell you
why they're doing it but it's so it cuts
too close to the bone for people and so
they think well we don't understand how
that can happen you know like there was
a while back I think it was in
Connecticut where there is a bunch of
elementary school kids shot right
because this is kind of a one-upmanship
game and it's bad enough to shoot high
school kids but it's even worse to shoot
kindergarten and elementary kids because
they're even clearly more innocent it's
like well that's that's part of that
vengeful spirit you know it better to
punish the innocent than the guilty if
you're trying to make a statement about
your your hatred for the structure of
reality and these things you have to
understand these things really you have
to understand them at a religious level
of analysis because there's no well
that's what happens when you encounter
evil is that you're into the domain that
can only be described by religious a
d--ation and I don't say that lightly
you know I've had many veterans come to
talk to me now and there are people who
had post-traumatic stress disorder and
they've said that listening to my
lectures has helped them out a lot
because it's provided them with a Phylis
philosophy of good and evil and if you
have post-traumatic stress disorder you
need a sophisticated philosophy of good
and evil because otherwise you don't
have any place to put your experiences
and that fragments and shatters you it's
it's no it's no trivial matter to be
touched by malevolence or to have it
manifest itself within you unexpectedly
you know it hurt it it's physiologically
destructive it shatters people and you
have to move from a naive interpretation
of the world to a very deep
interpretation of the world if you're
ever going to dig yourself out of that
hole you know that's that's interesting
in one of the
the things that I was gonna tell you or
ask you about so when I was a kid I I
wanted to be a commando like I don't
really remember wanting to do anything
else when I realized that there was that
role that you could play in life that's
what I wanted to do and and a lot of my
friends in the SEAL Teams wore the same
way that's what they wanted to do and
soon as they figured out like oh that's
that exists oh I can do that and I just
have to sign this piece of paper and go
do this stuff and then that's what I'll
be where does that come from well I mean
that that's a very good question I mean
I would say it's temperamental you know
people differ tremendously in their
temperaments and to think that there's a
warrior temperament is a perfectly
reasonable thing to think I mean there's
been whole cultures many many cultures
who were devoted to fostering that
warrior mentality you know where if you
weren't like that you were the outlier I
would say that's probably true of most
human cultures across most of time you
know we've been fortunate enough to live
in relatively peaceful times at least
the vast majority of us so the necessity
for that like right at the edges of
actual warfare is much less than it
might be under other historical
circumstances but but it's it's it's a
deep part of many people's nature and so
the question is what do you do with that
right and I mean one alternative
potential potentially is criminal
behavior and you know the fact that so
many people like watching movies about
bad guys you know is an indication of
how attractive that is to people and I
think the reason for that is is that
while Nietzsche observed at one point
that most of what people regard as
morality is just cowardice and what he
meant by that was that people don't do
bad things not because they're good but
because they're afraid to do the bad
things and then when they see people do
the bad things that are actually really
deeply attracted by that because it
speaks to part of them that could go
beyond the rules and that's actually a
necessary part it's a really necessary
part like you don't make men safe by
making the
week in fact you they're much more
dangerous when they're weak because
they'll stab you in the back when they
get the chance or take advantage of you
when you when they get the chance you
make men safe let's say by making them
strong and then by making sure that
they're disciplined and so you know
you've got people like you've got this
let's say warrior mentality that's a
part deep part of their temperament and
then you have some choices about what
you might do with that you might try to
discipline it and bring it under
voluntary control and integrate it into
your character in which it then it can
make you someone who's stalwart and
indomitable and and who will move
forward you know in the face of
tremendous risk and well that's the
optimal that's the optimal pathway if
you have that kind of temperament and I
I think like it's the men that have the
most what would you call it it's not
aggressive exactly but we'll leave it at
that aggressive and fearless
temperaments that can be the best men
but it's like having a very powerful dog
you better civil you better discipline
because otherwise it's going to be a
monster yeah well I had the I was a
rebellious kid right and I could have
easily gone down the path of crime and
as a matter of fact many of my friends
that I you know left when they stayed in
now at home they they did end up as
criminals and having big trouble with
the law or going down even paths of
drugs and everything else that you can
get into but but when we were kids or
younger everyone kind of had the same
thing but like you said I kind of just
so lucky because I just designed that
piece of paper and and I saw that I
could do something and I could take all
that aggression and all that energy I
could do something that was good and
positive and and we joke about that in
the SEAL Teams that many guys you you
you actually to be a good seal you sort
of you sort of have this criminal
mindset that you've you've somehow
harnessed and you keep under control
most of the time yeah
and occasionally it does get out of hand
and we got guys that get in trouble and
that happens and if we if we only took
guys that would never get in trouble we
wouldn't have anyone in the ranks really
well well you also see two in the
classic hero stories I mean you see this
with Harry Potter for example which I'm
making reference to because it was such
a phenomenon I mean when when something
makes welfare mother richer than the
Queen of England you shouldn't take note
right and when kids are reading 500 page
books in mutton and and standing in line
waiting for the next one and when you
produce a whole movie Empire around
something you should take note of that
well Harry Potter's little team aren't
the delinquents right who have no
discipline but they're also not the good
kids they're the kids who will break
rules when necessary and that's that's
the issue break rules when necessary now
the question is when is that necessary
well that's sort of the ultimate
ultimate ethical choice but you know
you're why did that work for you do you
think you know like what why was it well
two questions one would be why did you
decide to step into a discipline
structure I mean that's obviously very
difficult and why do you think you did
that and some of the other kids that you
knew that were like you didn't it was
really one of the most rebellious things
that I could do was to join the military
so I come from a small New England town
people get done with high school they go
to college they get a job as whatever
people get jobs as they follow that very
normal path and and I didn't even know
anyone that joined the military and and
so that was the most rebellious thing I
could do Oh College no education no I'm
gonna go be a commando that's what I'm
gonna do and and it was the most
rebellious thing I could do I think
that's one of the reasons why I did it
it was also a complete break away from
you know family okay I have no reliance
on you you know I'm going you don't have
to worry about me anymore I'm done I
will not rely on anyone else I will be
self-reliant which I
wanted to do and so I think those are
the main things that that got me there
and then what's great about it for me
was when I got there you have a
completely blank slate and you have very
clear directions of what you need to do
to to ascend the the dominance you do
this you do this you follow these rules
you you literally fold your underwear in
this way when you're going through boot
camp and you get a better grade on your
military performance so they give you
very clear rules that you're supposed to
follow and very clear tasks that you had
to do and and it was great for me
because it was a blank slate because
when I was in high school I was a I was
a screw-up not bad but not good and and
so I hadn't really set myself up
properly and now all of a sudden all I
had to do that that was all gone it
didn't matter that the past did not
matter at all I have completely blank
slate if you do this stuff properly
you'll you'll do well and you'll ascend
that yeah well that's that I are that's
a very interesting thing because then
it's not merely a matter of following a
set of arbitrary rules it's following a
set of rules that have a clear path to
success right that's a very different
thing and and that that's also something
that's honest because the rules of the
game are well-established and then if
you play it properly you get to win and
that's a big deal as well you know and
you mentioned the seal types and I've
met a number of people like that you
know they're they're they're capable of
breaking rules let's say or maybe even
inclined to break them but I also think
that that's this is part of the reason
that I'm an admirer of Carl Jung because
Jung makes it very clear that see he was
very interested in the barriers to
enlightenment
because if there's if there's such a
thing as being enlightened let's say
then why isn't everyone enlightened if
it's just a matter of taking the
glorious route and and following your
bliss let's say it's like well that
sounds pretty easy why isn't everyone
enlightened and but Jung's thinking
isn't like that at all you know he he
believed that in order to transform your
personality that first of all you had to
be disciplined that's for sure but you
also had to integrate that part of you
that was terrible and capable of
breaking rules and make it part of you
and so then and I really like that
idea well here here's an example so
about 20 years ago I would say there was
a newspaper headline in one accounted
his major newspapers and it was the
Minister of Foreign Affairs at that time
Lloyd Axworthy and he was talking about
what had happened with Milosevic and in
the former Soviet Union in Yugoslavia
and the atrocities that were being
committed and he said that he that he
was caught unawares by that because he
didn't have the imagination for that
kind of evil and I thought well you know
you think that what you're doing is
signaling your virtue by making a
statement like that but from my
perspective all you're doing is stating
your cowardice and your historical
ignorance because if you're gonna be
Minister of Foreign Affairs you bloody
well better have imagination for that
kind of evil because if you don't then
anyone who does wins they beat you and
so you you know and again in the Harry
Potter stories you see he's touched by
evil right he actually has a soul
fragment that's embedded within him
that's as black as anything can possibly
be that's why he could talk to snakes
but without that he wouldn't be able to
have any victory and that's exactly
right psychologically unless you can
think the way that an evil person thinks
then you're defenseless against them
because they'll go places you can't
imagine and then they win and so the
best man I've met died it was
interesting even when I was in junior
high in high school because most of my
friends dropped out you know by the time
their grade 10 thereabouts and a lot of
them were guys who developed physically
they're pretty powerful and they're just
damn sick and put up their hand to go to
the bathroom I was like you know they're
not doing that anymore one of my friends
got kicked out when he sort of
challenged the gym teacher you know
physically and the gym teacher he could
do an Iron Cross he was a tough guy and
so it was no trivial matter for my
friend to stand up to him but he got
expelled anyways but you know I noticed
that it wasn't it was often the kids
whose character I admired that either
quit or got expelled and they were the
tougher guys who were just sick and
tired of following rules that didn't
take into account their character and
then they'd go off and work on the oil
rigs or whatever and you could do that
Albert at that time that was really hard
work you know so it wasn't like they
were necessarily taking
the easy path but like a harmless man is
not a good man a good man is a very very
dangerous man
who has that under voluntary control and
you know you also see that like one of
the central mmm
female stories let's say if the hero
archetype is the central male story
there are variants of hero archetypes
that are relevant to women and one of
them is Beauty and the Beast
and you know Beauty isn't interested in
the guy who isn't the Beast
she's interested in the guy who's the
Beast and that's exactly right but she's
interested in the guy who's the Beast
that can be civilized and disciplined
right and who can use that in the
service well let's say of a family and
and that's exactly well that's exactly
how it should be so I gave a speech one
of my very good friends got married a
few years ago and I gave a speech and at
this speech he was a friend of mine seal
and at the speech I was talking about
what it was to be a man and what when I
felt like I was a man and I said there
was three things that that I felt let me
transition from being you know mentally
insecure about who I was as a person to
being okay I'm actually good with Who I
am
number one was learning how to fight and
you know I got into Brazilian jiu-jitsu
and mixed martial arts and I learned how
to fight and now all of a sudden when I
looked at other people I didn't I wasn't
posturing I wasn't trying to pretend
that I was tough I was I knew that most
people that I would encounter I could
defeat in a physical altercation that
was number one
number two was going into combat because
even though you might be tough on him in
a street fight or in a fistfight with
someone when you're facing death well
that's a whole nother level and for me
going into combat well what was I gonna
act like was I gonna be scared was I
gonna be a coward was I gonna be scared
of death and when I went into combat I
wasn't I was fine I was okay with the
fact that I could die and
and I was okay with that and I made good
decisions and and did what I was
supposed to do and the last one was a
cop married and had kids because all of
a sudden all these things these being
aggressive and working to fight and be
able to destroy in an efficient way well
then I took that and combined it with
okay now I'm gonna take care of these my
wife and our children and that's what
I'm gonna do and my point in giving this
speech was he was a guy that had learned
how to fight he was a guy that had been
in combat and now there was one more
step to take which was okay now you're
gonna get married and you're gonna take
care of these people so it's interesting
that that once again that dichotomy that
that you talk about it fits perfectly
into the way I figure things out as a
guy that went to high school and join
the military it's kind of its kind of
really but it reinforces what you always
say which is that there's there's deeper
meaning there's a reason why I'm
thinking that and the reason is because
I've because of the things that you talk
about the way these things are overlaid
throughout history for human beings to
have gotten to this point yeah well you
acted it out you know which is what
you're supposed to do and it's also it's
better to act it out and to understand
it you know that's that's best it's
better it's better to understand it and
not act it out than to not understand it
at all but the best is to act it out and
understand it and because then you can
you know then then the way that you
represent the world and yourself is in
accordance with the way that you act and
that's that's that's optimized yeah and
it's it's something that I was kind of
acting out again no no real guy like my
guidelines were like I was raised in the
SEAL Teams yeah that was sort of my
guidelines it and here's a good example
when I first got in the SEAL Teams
there's no war going on so what did what
did a good seal do you know you did you
went out and drank and gotten bar fights
mm-hmm that's what a good seal did so
you know what I did went out drank
gotten bar fights that's what okay
that's what I'm supposed to do it took
me a while to figure out though there's
actually something more than that like
we're actually supposed to be preparing
for war and and and so now like you said
I I definitely acted things out and sort
of was on a decent path but as I got
older and more mature and to this day as
I can look around and actually overlay
the understanding
the way I've carried out my life is very
it's very helpful to me and it also
helps me explain it to other people that
see the path at home and go they they
like that path they would like to join
me on that path and I get guys that you
know when I was in I I you know I can't
look like a serial killer for all
practical purposes I'm that's the way I
come across right
nobody was not creepy enough there's
there's guys that would you know guys
that would work for me or guys that
would be around me and they'd see me and
they'd kind of latch on to the fact that
I was tough and aggressive and and and
some of those guys they wouldn't catch
the other part which was that I was
politically savvy and I was working and
I was maneuvering and I was you know
figuring things out and talking to my
boss in such a way that we could get
where we needed to be and I was doing
that whole other side and so I get these
guys that would end up not doing as well
as they should do because they were just
hey jock was just ultra aggressive and
he gets after it and so that's what I'm
gonna do and I'll be in the same place
the guys that would do well the guys
that said oh yeah jock was awesome and
he's aggressive and he gets after it
he's also working and he's also
maneuvering he's also massaging the egos
of the people around him so make sure
that they get positioned in the right
spot where they can go to warp off in
the right way and and so as I've gotten
older I've been able to tell people that
more clearly like hey it's not just
about that side of the ultra-aggressive
you got to be aggressive you got to be
willing to fight you got to be willing
to kill and you got to be willing to die
at the same time you got to be able to
tamper and temper all those things in
such a way that they can be controlled
and disciplined well I also think that
that's part of what makes a world
peaceful in the final analysis because
if you're around people who are
dangerous but disciplined then everyone
watches their step and that's exactly
what should happen everybody should
watch their step and if you do if
there's no reason for that then well
there's no there's no sanction for for
poor behavior for example like I mean if
you if you're going to discipline a
child the child has to be convinced that
you're a force that's worthy of paying
attention to you know I see kids there's
a chapter in my book
called don't ever don't let your
children do anything that makes you
dislike them and I'm pretty happy about
this chapter although I suspect it'll be
rather controversial and you know it's
predicated first on the observation that
many people hurt their children
physically and psychologically
you know because everyone gets
sentimental about the relationship
between parents and children but that's
especially in relationship to themselves
because they think well you know of
course I'm going to be a good parent
it's like it's not so bloody obvious
that you're gonna be a good parent you
know and so and then what I see
happening with people who don't know how
to discipline their children is that the
children run roughshod over them in
there let's call them hierarchical
disputes because children push for
position in hierarchy and they do that
behaviorally to sort of feel out the
contours of the social structure so you
know your kid like perfectly fine at
home let's say at the dinner table but
then you take them to a stranger's
dinner table and all of a sudden they
act out and you think what's up with you
you little monster and what's up is that
they're trying to figure out what the
power structure is in the new they don't
know this of course but they're acting
this out they're trying to figure out if
the same rules apply in this new
situation as apply in the old situation
and they can't ask that and they don't
even know that they are rules exactly
there are regularities that they've
learned and so they'll test and test and
then you have to show them that yeah
it's the same here it's the same in this
situation but lots of parents are very
uneasy with disciplining their children
partly because they're they believe that
if you give a child infinite freedom
that's best for them and that
constraints are inappropriate which is
really just well I don't know what to
say about that except it's so untrue
that that it's very difficult to think
of anything that's more untrue than that
but also the thing is is if you let your
children take advantage of you if you
have an ounce of spine and an ounce of
aggression which you do especially if
you don't admit it then you will take
revenge on your children you know so if
they have a temper tantrum in a grocery
store and embarrass you which a child
whose County can do quite effectively
you know because you wouldn't let them
have that pack of crayons or a chocolate
bar and and then you know you
you tell yourself it's okay and that you
still you know that that really didn't
make you that angry and it's okay but
you're filming inside and then you go
home and half an hour later maybe the
child is doing some interesting little
bit of work maybe artwork or something
or does something good and comes up for
a reward it's like the probability that
you're gonna reward that child properly
under those circumstances zero you're
gonna take the opportunity to take your
revenge and if you don't know that then
you're not much of a parent and so part
of the trick with kids is that if your
child is doing something that makes you
dislike them that you have to figure out
how to stop them from doing that and
teach them how to do it properly and you
have to talk to your wife to make sure
that you're not being too much of a
monster you know and the same with her
but that that discipline is partly what
enables you to continue to like your
child well you love them and even more
than that you know parents talk about
fostering self-esteem and fostering
creativity and all of that and their
kids and I think that's misbegotten it's
shallow for a variety of reasons first
it's not that easy to foster creativity
because it's rare and self-esteem is a
very badly defined concept and mostly
it's been used for harm not good what
your job is as a parent is to help your
child learn from between two years old
and say four years old how to act in the
world so that when people encounter them
people smile and are happy they're
around because then you know I've seen
kids who behave badly and everywhere
they go people wear false smiles and
everywhere they go people are relieved
when they leave and that means you think
about that world from the child's
perspective everyone's lying and all
everyone hates them that's their world
and then if you have your child you know
capable of adhering to minimal social
requirements like maybe being able to
sit at the tables in a civilized manner
for an hour and being grateful for being
fed let's say and knowing how to share
and knowing how to pay attention to
adults and and not having that you know
that kind of terrible cynicism and and
arrogance that
develop even in the four-year-old child
who's always had its way then then
they'll interact with adults in a manner
that bring out the best and the adults
and every year they go everyone smiles
at them and Pat's them on the head maybe
even tells them useful and interesting
things and so the whole world opens up
for them and that's all a consequence of
you having enough courage to admit to
yourself that your child can do things
that you don't like and that you will
take it out on them if you don't
straighten it out and people don't like
that idea because they think well I'd
never do anything you know I love my
child I'd never do anything to hurt them
it's like yeah Oh God right you know
you're so you're so asleep if you think
that that that there's almost no hope
for you you have to think I'm way bigger
than this child and I'm way meaner and
I'm wait Rekia and I'm Way more
unpredictable and so I better be very
careful in my relationships with this
child so that the worst of me doesn't
come out and then that gives you enough
intelligence to make a disciplinary
framework that's minimal and enforce it
properly and carefully and then you can
have an unbelievably good relationship
with your kids so and this idea of
discipline obviously I talk about
discipline a lot and one of the things
you were talking about earlier with
regards to veterans and people that have
listened to your lectures and it's the
same thing with me people that listen to
this podcaster or read the books and and
one of the things that I've noticed and
I've talked about and I've gotten a lot
of positive feedback on is you know when
you're in the military you have this
discipline and beyond that beyond the
discipline that's imposed on you you
also have a lot that you have to just
hold the line yourself I mean when
you're in the military sure you go
through boot camp where there's a drill
instructor that jellien and all that but
it once you're in the military you're
doing what you have to do it's self
discipline that you learn that and you
become self disciplined and what happens
is guys get out and that's that's gone
and that hurts them and the other thing
that hurts them is they don't know what
their mission is anymore
and and my big thing with people
I've been telling vets now is find what
your next mission is go find whatever
your next mission and I don't care what
it is but it has to be something and I
was listening to you talk on something
the other day and and you were you were
talking about how not doing anything
when people are not going anywhere when
they're when they're failing when
they're when they don't have the drive
it's because they're not accepting
responsibility for anything and and so
my way of saying that is like you need a
new mission you can't be responsible for
something and you need to go and move
towards some new mission and and do you
encounter people that or you see people
that's very problematic in the civilian
side as well where people they just
don't know what they're doing yeah don't
take responsibility for anything that's
a part of this nihilism you know is that
because first of all you learn the truth
is relevant relative and that there's no
real moral order and you know that
alleviates you of responsibility and
that's why that's such an attractive
message to people but the problem is is
that it kills you it kills your soul so
to speak because well when we can talk
about this technically so you know there
are systems neurological systems that
underlie your experience of negative
emotion and there are neurological
systems that underlie your experience of
positive emotion and there are separate
systems they obviously interact but
they're separate systems so but the
positive emotion system well there's two
of them but one of them sort of kicks in
when you get something that you want so
you know you're hungry and you eat and
that feels good and so that's kind of
the simple one
but there's a more sophisticated one
that I think is even more active in
people and it's the one that tells you
that you're moving forward towards
something worthwhile and that's actually
the one that gives people that sense of
a meaningful engagement in their life on
a moment-to-moment basis so and and it's
also it's also something that doesn't
have to go away like if you're hungry
and you eat well that's good but it's
over and then you're on to the next
thing right it's not exactly sustaining
it's just necessary that's called
consume Ettore reward by the way this
other reward system is incentive reward
and the incentive reward system works on
dopamine this neurochemical dopamine
would
is also the neurochemical tracks that
opiates and cocaine and amphetamines the
drugs that people really like to abuse
alcohol often for some people activate
and so you might say if you don't have
enough meaning in your life then you're
more prone to addiction and that's
definitely the case even with rats if
you take a rat you put him in a cage by
himself and he has nothing to do and
then you give him access to cocaine
he'll get addicted to the point where he
won't do anything but take cocaine but
if you throw the rat back in with a
bunch of other rats and he gets to do
rat things then it's very hard to get
him addicted to cocaine and so the
purposeless rat is prone to addiction
well it's the same with human beings now
here's a corollary to that which is
really cool so the magnitude of the
reward you experience as you're moving
towards a goal is proportionate to the
importance of the goal so that means the
more important the goal you pick the
more possibility there is for the kind
of reward let's say it's really a state
of being that is life-affirming and it
is directly life-affirming in that you
know like if you're in a football game
and you're and it's an important
football game and maybe you break a
finger and you know normally that's
that's a problem it hurts and you're
gonna stop doing whatever you're doing
but if you're right in the middle of the
game then you'll be so amped up on this
reward system that its analgesic it
stops the pain it also suppresses
anxiety so if you have a purpose then
its analgesic it takes some of the pain
out of life it's very positive in that
it motivates and energizes you and
focuses you and makes you able to
remember and pay attention and it quells
fear and so those things are all direct
and so then you might think well what's
the best possible goal well and that's
that's the purpose I would say of
religious training and philosophical
training it's like just what the hell
are you doing in the world you know when
I would say well that's actually fairly
easy - also - also lay out and this is
why nihilism is a much weaker
philosophical position than it might
appear to be it's like well there are
lots of terrible things happening in the
world if you're not I don't care if
you're a believer in atheist er
or a cynic of the highest sort you
listen to a story like the one that you
wrote read at the beginning of the of
this podcast and no one says well in a
hundred thousand years who the hell
cares so why does it matter no one says
that they listen to that not if they're
human they listen to that story and they
think that's not good
it's like that's right that's not good
it's not good you should do something
about that because it's it's it it's
it's self-evidently not good so you
might say well at least you can start
your self-organization by improving
those things around you that are self
evidently not good and that's easy man
anybody can do this you can sit down for
ten minutes say well I'm going to be
honest with myself like that's a
horrible thing to do I'm going to be
honest with myself okay I'm probably
doing a dozen stupid things that I could
quit doing that are making my life less
more wretched and also the people around
me and so you think okay what are those
things and you know if you really want
to know you have to want to know and
you're gonna get a bunch of information
that you don't want to hear but you'll
know it's true and you already knew it
in some sense and then you can ask
yourself okay that's sucks and it's
miserable and it's not very self
affirming is there one of those things I
would I would be willing to do something
about that I would actually do something
about you know that I could do something
about that I would do something about
which is also another horrible question
because as soon as you get an answer to
that then you have a responsibility
right it's like oh god I have to go do
that and it's something you don't want
to do you don't want to do it that's why
you've been avoiding it and so then it's
right in front of you and it's like it's
some little trivial horrible thing that
you're not gonna get a pat on the back
for no one's gonna give you an award for
it and and most people would just say
Jesus you should have done that a long
time ago you [ __ ] and but then you go
do it that's kind of humility I would
say and then you keep doing that and
it's like there's this injunction in the
New Testament against praying in public
you know and it's like virtue signaling
it's like you don't pray in public
because then you go out and
you'd show everybody just what a great
believer you are and how good you are
it's like well that's what you're doing
you're not trying to get your act
together that's something you do in
private at home you think okay what kind
of [ __ ] am i and what stupid things am
i doing and then what could I possibly
do to get rid of one of those a little
bit now well anybody can do that and
that's associated with these great evils
you know in this way that we've already
described it's like you're constraining
you're improving your character and
you're constraining the kinds of actions
and perceptions that you have that are
gonna make you sick of life and work
against it because failure does that
that's the Keynes story it's like keep
screwing up man
see what happens if you think that isn't
gonna make you bitter and if that isn't
gonna make you vengeful and if that
isn't gonna make you work to hurt people
around you or at least not to help them
which is the same thing then you're just
not paying attention everyone knows
that's true so well that's
responsibility right and then so you
take on this great task of putting
yourself together it gives you life
meaning and that also helps you be
brought just against the fact that
there's lots of suffering in life and
there's lots of malevolence it's like
yeah true man
absolutely it's worse than you think
even but you can do more about it than
you think and there's nothing in it
except good but you also have to take
responsibility so that's the thing you
got to decide if that's what you're
gonna do but you don't get to whine
about it if you don't because you
haven't tested it so people don't even
have to look for some grand goal in the
sky some elevated goal of what they're
gonna do whether it's a financial goal
whether it's a non-profit goal and
they're gonna they can look around their
bedroom and figure out what they're
gonna do right now well what improve
things one of the things I learned from
reading Solzhenitsyn is he talked about
his moral transformation in the camps
and he said the first thing that
transformed him to some degree was
looking at people in the camps who did
refuse to do immoral things no matter
what he said he ran into people like
that and that just blew him away because
you already laid that out it's like
these are he said they were too
choosing between their life and their
conscience and they chose their
conscience like and and he tells some
amazing stories in The Gulag Archipelago
about you know dozens of people he meant
like that met like that and they're just
there's stories that of heroism moral
heroism under absolutely vicious
conditions there you just can't believe
them you know so so that's pretty
amazing but he said that once he kind of
figured out that there was a difference
between attending to your conscience and
doing whatever was necessary to prolong
your miserable existence that he started
to think about that deeply and that he
went over his life with a fine-tooth
comb and tried to figure out everything
he did that he knew was wrong and then
to try to figure out what he could do in
the present to rectify that you know you
wouldn't necessarily be able to to atone
that's the right that's the right way of
thinking about it you know you do
something wrong and well maybe you can't
even fix it with the person you did the
wrong to but maybe there's something
else you could do that would be good
enough so that you know you can think
okay well at least those balance out and
maybe I'm a little bit on the side of
the positive so he did that you know and
that he said that's straightened him out
a lot and then he wrote this book this
amazing book that you know cut the
communist intellectuals off at their
knees and and changed the world really
and that's a hell of a thing for someone
to do who's a you know miserable Zek in
a in a concentration camp that's a hell
of a story man and it's not the only one
like it so you don't know how much power
you have where you stand even if you
look weak and and and if what's around
you is terrible well then you've got
lots of things to do that's for sure and
they're announcing themselves right
there so and well and it's tying it in
with evil and suffering that is best for
me because it's so real you know it's
like you can be skeptical about the
existence of the good but if you if you
open your eyes and you do any amount of
studying and even any amount of
self-examination you can't be skeptical
about the existence of evil I don't
believe that you can there are things
that read about unit 731 and then see
how skeptical you are about evil I
wouldn't recommend
that by the way because that's that is
so horrible that you can't really read
it without being traumatized it is
unbelievably horrible you read that and
then you say well morality is relative
it's like see if you can mater those
words after reading that and then if
morality isn't relative and there is
evil then there is good it's at least
whatever isn't evil right you can
whatever doesn't cause that is good it's
sort of defining it by its opposite but
that's okay it doesn't matter it's good
enough and so how do how do guys going
back to the the PTSD conversation a
little bit how do you guys that sort of
experienced this evil part of not only
of the world but of themselves cuz they
had to do some things that they didn't
want to do or they didn't like doing and
things that made them feel like uhm
there's a dark part of me that I don't
really like too much what's the what's
the you know from what I've said is you
gotta embrace that that the fact that
there's darkness in the world and that
there's darkness in you you got to
embrace that and get a hold of it not
try and disguise it not try and make it
seem like it's not there that's the same
thing you're saying right yeah well you
know when you're in really did they say
there's no atheists in foxholes you know
and and that's that's you know it's a
bit of a cliche but but there's there's
a deep truth in that which is in there's
some circumstances that you find
yourself in for which only religious
language works and if you happen to do
observe yourself doing something that's
highness enough to damage you
psychologically then you're in the realm
of good and evil archetypal good and
evil and and unless you can start to
conceptualize the world in that manner
you're never going to make sense out of
it and so partly it D personalizes it
you know it's it's you that did this but
it's like the capacity for evil isn't
just you it's it's part of humanity
maybe it's part of the structure of the
cosmos and you happen to stumble over it
naively and so it hurt you you know
there's this old Egyptian story about a
god named Horus and he's the god of
attention so he's represented by the
Egyptian eye so he pays attention
he's also a Falken and Falken has great
vision and flies above everything right
and and he's also the the force that
revitalizes the dead farther in in
egyptian mythology but he has a fight
with his evil uncle set who is a
precursor to the idea of satan and then
you can tell by partly because the words
are quite similar and he has a terrible
battle with Seth who's taken over the
kingdom and and is a terrible tyrant and
is killing everyone and and everything's
going to hell and he has a battle with
him to regain control of his kingdom and
that's fine and he's a god and so is set
and they have a fight and it's a
terrible fight and during the fight seth
tears out one of his eyes when you think
well that's a god right and nonetheless
he ends up with his vision damaged his
consciousness damaged now he gains a
different kind of sight he gains insight
right because now he knows the nature of
evil but he pays a big price for it and
so you think well if that's the case for
a god how much more is it the case for a
man to be damaged it's like absolutely
right it's no joke to encounter
malevolence you know I've seen that in
my clinical clients too I had a client
who was terrified into nightly
convulsions for four years by the look
on her boyfriend's face when he attacked
her it took me a long time to unpack
that it was like a three-month process
but it was the it was see she was very
naive very very very naive because her
parents had raised her in a world where
the Evil Queen was not allowed to visit
like the parents and Sleeping Beauty so
she was way too sheltered and she
thought that human beings were only good
you know and then she saw the look on
his face that indicated that he was out
to consciously harm her and he he
couldn't they had a fight a physical
fight and she was strong enough to to
prevail he wasn't that big but that
wasn't the point it shattered her world
because she didn't understand until that
point that someone could actually
consciously want to hurt you you know
that that wasn't just they weren't just
in a bad mood and it wasn't just because
of the way they were raised and you know
all those excuses that people come up
that he was not only going to hurt her
but he was going to enjoy it
and if you don't understand the part
of you that's capable of that then well
you're you're dangerously dangerously
naive and dangerous as well because you
don't know what you're capable of so a
lot of these things that you bring up
are about leadership and and you know I
talk about leadership all the time
and one of the things that you know I
heard you say and you've talked about
with with chimpanzees and other
hierarchies that are out there including
lobsters which I know you like quite a
bit and you know even lobsters have a
dominance hierarchy which is which is
definitely incredible since how big is
their brain oh it's it's not like it's
mostly distributed through their bodies
I mean it's not that big and yeah it is
absolutely unbelievable to know that the
hierarchical arrangement like it's a the
reason it's a symbolic reality so that
would be the great father let's say the
reason that's a symbolic reality is
because you can't see a hierarchy like
if you look at the world you don't see a
hierarchy but chimps know exactly where
each chimp is in the hierarchy so for
example a low-ranking mature chimp won't
attack a high-ranking juvenile even
though he could tear him apart
because he knows that that juvenile is
actually an illusion the juvenile is the
juvenile plus all the other chimps that
will come to his rescue right so he
can't perceive the hierarchy with his
eyes but he can perceive the hierarchy
with his emotions okay so that hierarchy
is essentially eternal it's at least 350
million years old and it's and we
perceive that all the time we look at
hierarchical posturing we look at we and
we live in hierarchies of competence
mostly so that's that's that's a
universal truth and the fact that you
have to struggle with the fact of the
hierarchy is also universal truth and
you actually see this being played out
to some degree in the leftist feminist
arena because really what's happening is
they they look at the hierarchy let's
say the male high
your key they don't attribute it to it
mmm competence they attribute to it
power and they make the presupposition
that you get to the top by being the
meanest most exploitive creature
possible and so these are often damaged
women who've never had a good
relationship with men with a man and who
can't distinguish between competence and
power there's a big difference because
hierarchy that's only based on power is
a tyranny but a hierarchy based on
competence is something that gets things
done like that's exactly what you want
in a hierarchies that the competent
people climb the hierarchy so you can
tell who's competent out the top and you
you made reference to the chimpanzee
work I mean friends the wall has showed
quite clearly that unstable chimp power
hierarchies are based on tyranny so it
is that the ugliest meanest brute of a
chimp gets to the top but like as soon
as he has a bad day than two 3/4 as
strong chimps tear them into pieces and
the chimps that manage to maintain power
at the top or let's say Authority
because that's a better work because we
got to get our words right that's a
chimp that has friends and that engages
in reciprocal grooming and that pays
reasonable attention to the females and
so it's so interesting to see that
because it shows that even at that level
of biological organization there's
already a morality of leadership yeah
that what we're that strikes me is so
interesting and I try to explain this to
people all the time because well in the
SEAL Teams again you you might think the
same thing well the biggest toughest
seal that can destroy everyone else is
gonna be the leader that everyone looks
to and it's just not true and in fact a
lot of times those guys that might be
the biggest and the strongest and the
fastest they're they're actually
arrogant as well because they've they
think they can beat everyone and no one
wants to work for those people and so it
happened when I first started my
consulting business and and I would have
you know a CEO say I can't wait till you
come in and just whip my people into
shape and I'd say well you need to find
somebody else that's gonna wet people in
mache
because I don't do that and and they
couldn't quite put together that me
would wasn't into whipping people in the
shape and know what I wanted to actually
do is teach people to lead and to lead
people my selves if and when you're
leading you're not having to whip people
in fact yeah that's an indication that
you're not lead exactly that way as a
leader where I the the place where I
usually found myself was I'm actually
having to pull the reins back on people
because they're going far and away above
what I actually would even want and
expect them to do they want to go even
more and do more to accomplish the
mission then that's where you want to
get and I find it interesting that you
know you talk about that all the time
that it's and it's not the person with
the biggest club it's not the person
that's the meanest and the most
aggressive sure they might they might
rise for a minute they might get some
control and that happens in any
organization oh if you've got a CEO that
really he's just a tyrant and everyone's
scared of him he can make some things
happen for a little while and then all
of a sudden someone says I'm oh he wants
us to do it that way I'm gonna do a
little sabotage right just a little
sabotage your project that you want us
to get done by October 31st Oh get got
delayed boss yeah you can go nuts and
you can yell and scream but you should
have listened to me when I said we
needed more time and now guess where we
are yeah we didn't deliver the product
we're supposed to deliver so you can
yell and scream all you want
it's not gonna get that product
delivered yeah well any few tyrannize
people badly enough they'll actually
hurt themselves to hurt you
so you know they're willing to take a
they're willing to take a hit to reclaim
justice let's say so yeah that's really
worth knowing and so one of the things
that John Piaget pointed out and because
he was he's a very interesting
psychologist a and and and he's never
taught properly because you know most of
these great thinkers were very strange
people and the strangeness gets added
out of their stories and it's really too
bad because they're way more interesting
when you know how strange they were and
so Piaget was obsessed with the
disjunction between religion and science
and his goal as a thinker was to
reconcile the two
and so to some degree he was looking for
a biological basis of morality that
might be one way of thinking about it or
at least to reconcile the idea of a
biological substrate with an emergent
morality and one of the things he said
is okay imagine two systems
alright so both systems are moving
towards a goal
any old arbitrary goal and in one system
the the people within interacting under
compulsion and in the other system the
people within it are acting voluntarily
said the people who are acting
voluntarily will defeat the people
acting under compulsion because in order
to use compulsion you have to spend a
fair bit of time and energy on force and
so it makes you inefficient
whereas if everybody is together on the
project then they'll you don't have to
spend any time on compulsion because
people are compelling themselves and so
that's what he called an equilibrate
state so an equilibrate the state was
well we sit down and we have a
negotiation it's a real negotiation so
it has to be honest and we say okay well
what the hell are we doing
and everyone hashes that out and we
decide what we're doing and then we
decide how that would be good for all of
us but each of us singularly as well so
if you got your family put together
properly then the whole family moves
together but everybody inside moves
ahead as well and so then everybody's
pushing in the same you know you know
how it is what in a negotiation you
actually want your interests to align
with the interests of the other person
because then you don't have to worry
about the integrity of the deal it's
like everybody has reasons to keep it to
keep it thriving and the idea that
capitalism in somehow is somehow is
predicated on the tyranny of the people
at the at the pinnacle that happens when
it gets corrupt but it doesn't happen at
all when it's working properly because
deals that aren't based on mutual
self-interest and group interest
simultaneously have to be enforced
usually with lawyers and then you're
done right you're done at that point
that's that's actually incredible so I
would when I worked with companies ever
I was working with a company they're a
couple of years ago maybe even three or
four years ago and you know they were
talking about how they needed to hold
their salespeople accountable and that's
what they needed to do and they needed
more accountability in the sales
leadership underneath them needed to
hold all their
frontline sales leaders accountable for
everything and follow these rules and
make these numbers of calls and do these
follow-up things and send the follow-up
emails and they need to get this
accountability thing going and this was
the winner when I heard this guy saying
this is the first time I said because I
heard this a lot this is word
accountability and leadership you hear
oh well we just need better
accountability better accountability and
it's a trick because you think about it
and you say to yourself well if I'm in
charge of you guys and I'm gonna hold
you accountable to make sure you do
everything you're supposed to do well
then we will successfully do what it is
you you will do because I held you
accountable I made you do it
the problem is in any organization
there's too many people to hold everyone
accountable to everything that they're
supposed to be doing stuff just doesn't
work and so you could take one group and
this is what I said I said if you've got
one group where you have to hold them
accountable for each and everything that
you do and you and you try and do that
versus a group where people know what
they're supposed to do and they want to
go and do it and go which which team is
gonna win and these another group that
wants to do themselves like oh that's
what you need to do is get them to want
to do with themselves that's leadership
that's well exactly that's exactly right
I mean look if you get people to track
everything they do it takes them longer
to track and then to do it plus they
hate it they hate it because they're not
being trusted and it's the most terrible
dull administrative work and it just
kills people who are actually productive
because they're driven crazy by that
it's like leave me the hell alone so I
can do my work you know and so yeah so
so there's something that here's an
interesting little fact that I think is
really cool I found this out this is
from the psychological literature so
I've been interested in how to increase
people's motivation for a long time you
know and and there's a nice literature
on that and and part of it was as was
created by late Latham and Locke Gary
Latham and Edwin Locke and they're
looking at goal-setting that's how well
they described it as a means to improve
business productivity and so what they
imagined that you have two teams and you
get them to set goals and one team sets
goals for their corporate productivity
and another team sets goals for their
life and then you match them
head-to-head over some period of time
and see which one comes up
and what happens is the people who set
goals for their life beat the people who
set goals for the company and so that's
really and then there's a variety of
other literature's that support that
kind of hypothesis but it's it's it's
very very worthwhile thinking that
through because what you want if your
company is structured properly if you
want people in it who have a life right
so they're aiming at things that they
think are valuable because they're just
not going to be motivated period unless
they're aiming at things they think are
valuable and then you want their loyalty
that to the company to be nested inside
that so they have to see that working
there no matter what it is that they're
doing and now you know often jobs are
repetitive and dull and difficult and
and challenging and all of that or you
wouldn't be paid to do them right
they're not all fun and games but if you
can see that the less intrinsically
interesting things that you're required
to do are related in some directly
intelligible way to goals that you
regard as valuable then that tags those
activities with this dopaminergic kick
that we were talking about earlier so
you need this hierarchy of values right
just like here's what I'm doing with my
life here's why my job is important to
that or maybe it isn't and then you have
to quit and go find a new job but that's
fine but you know because you might
discover that too and so we started
trying to formalize this but at the same
time that I also realized something that
I've never recovered from realizing I
think so I teach students usually for
this class it was third and fourth-year
students and so this is at the
University of Toronto they're pretty
smart kids it's a hard university to get
into and they're pretty disciplined and
they're actually quite conservative all
things considered and I was teaching
them about stories and about the fact
that our life is a story with a goal and
a purpose and and a beginning point and
and I was encouraging them to develop
their own stories so I had them write an
autobiography and they really got into
that that was quite amazing to identify
you know to break their life into epochs
and then to describe the important
episodes in each epoch both positive and
negative and what they might do to
the possibility of the negative in the
future and to capitalize on the positive
which is the purpose of memory by the
way and then also to write a plan for
the future and so we we formalized that
so the plan is okay first of all you
have to get yourself in the right
mindset and the mindset is you're trying
to take care of yourself like you would
care for someone that you cared for now
it's a hard mindset to get into because
people like their pets better than they
like themselves often mm-hmm and then
you have to have a vision and so the
vision would be well okay three to five
years down the road if your friendship
networks were configured properly what
would that look like if you were
pursuing the career that would be
appropriate for you and sustaining for
you what would that look like how are
you going to educate yourself how are
you going to take care of yourself
mentally and physically what do you want
for an intimate relationship and how are
you going to handle temptations like
alcohol and drug abuse because they take
people down pretty frequently so all you
have to do is think about okay
what could that be like if you had what
you needed not some wild fantasy but but
realistic and what you needed so that's
the first part and then okay now write
for 20 minutes about what your life
could be like three to five years down
the road if all of this came together
and then now do the opposite so imagine
all your weaknesses and all the ways
that you can go down the wrong path and
then imagine that gets the upper hand
then imagine where you are in three to
five years so then you get a polarity a
it's like not this and then and yes this
so you can run away from the things you
don't want and you can run towards the
things you do want that gets your
anxiety behind you instead of in front
of you right because maybe you're gonna
go do something difficult and you're
afraid of it and then you think well if
I don't do this I'm gonna end up there
it's like oh okay that's so terrible
that this little terrible is nothing so
and then in the next part of the
exercise you turn that into an
implementable plan you know and you
write about why your life would be
better and why your family's life would
be better and why your community's life
would be better so it's like fully
articulated and we've tested about
10,000 university students without now
in three different locales and we've
increased the probability that they'll
stay in university by about 30% and
raised their grade point average about
the same and it's worked best for men
who are most who were doing the least
well so in Holland those were
non-western ethnic minority men and they
improved their performance enough to
actually slightly exceed the Dutch
national women who were at the top
otherwise over two years yeah it was
unbelievable it just blew us away it's a
psychological intervention to cure
What's in hypothetically a sociological
problem and so and so that that's a good
example of how and it did what blew me
away when I was first considering this
is I had all these students 21 years old
and I realized that no one had ever sat
them down not even once in their entire
career in education it said okay
who do you want to be like what sort of
person is it that you want to be not not
job it's like character what do you want
your life to be like what should it be
like and what shouldn't it be like and
like write about that seriously like
your life depends on it because it does
and and then I thought well that's so
weird why in the world isn't our
education system set up to help people
with that because it's like that's kind
of obvious you know it's like what are
you doing and why and then I did some
reading partly from John Gatto who's
done some interesting work looking at
the history of the education system and
it was a derivation of the Prussian
education system back in the late 1800s
and it was designed to produce obedient
obedient well it was partly soldiers but
it was partly workers I was gonna say it
definitely was soldiers cuz yeah that
was the transition when they they had
the transition take place at that time
as well where they moved away from
centralized command after they got beat
by Napoleon and they never they were
constantly trying to fight towards that
direction where the soldiers would not
just be obedient because they realized
that that is not what they actually
wanted they don't they finally started
to do at the end of World War one and
and if they would have done it earlier
it might have turned the tide of the war
but that was what
you know that's what world war two the
Blitzkrieg and and total decentralized
command and elements just going out and
making things happen and finding gaps in
the defenses and attacking them as
opposed to you're just gonna wait until
you're told what to do right and that
was the the German way and decentralized
command so right yes well well
competence beats obedience right so you
unite people under a goal and then you
let them act autonomously you got to get
them you got to not sell them the goal
that's not right you know what you have
to do is you have to go in and talk to
them and discover what the goal is of
the enterprise and what it is that fires
people up and that really does work you
know and the idea that capitalism is
essentially crooked and it's the people
who are who are pulling the wool over
other people's eyes who win is like well
you know now and then there's a criminal
action and the person gets away with it
so to speak although people get away
with a lot less than they think but most
of the time within a functional company
you better have your people on board or
they will do exactly what you said
they'll do they'll spend 80 percent of
their time sabotaging the company yeah
and I I again something I learned
working with the corporate world and it
was working with the corporate world
where I reflected on what I did and and
was talking to a elite of business
leader at some point and I said well you
know your people can understand why
they're doing what they're doing and so
then he's you know absorbs that and says
okay that's make sense and so then he
gets up in front of his team and he says
you know well the reason why we're doing
this is we want to improve our
profitability as a company and you know
he sat down and we talked afterwards he
said did I did I do a good job cuz now
they understand that's it oh no actually
you missed it and then I started
explaining to them better because I
learned that what you have to explain
there has to be a thread of why that
goes all the way through the corporate
reason but that why has to come back
down to the individual contributor so
they realize that when when we do better
as a company when we're more profitable
as a company we can put more money in or
in marketing and we can produce stuff
cheaper because we'll do it on a more
mass scale than we can lower prices and
then we can actually
hire more people that's gonna make you
move up in this command here you're
gonna make more money we're gonna sell
more stuff and you're gonna get a bigger
bonus so you doing this the reason why
you're doing it is cuz then you can
achieve those life goals because I want
to buy that house and that car and send
your kid to school so there's a big
difference you need to make sure that
the people understand why they're doing
it not for the corporate reason not for
the mission reason but for for why it's
gonna help them the exact same thing you
just said yeah it's also really helpful
to if you you know your corporation has
I hate to use the word vision because
that's you know turned into a buzzword
but you know it's often that you're
working a company where worthwhile
things are happening exciting and
worthwhile things you know and you're
you're trying to well make something
better at a lower price let's say and so
there's the the heroism let's say of
producing a product that's going to have
a positive impact on the world and you
need to know how your small actions are
tied with that greater goal and then
there's this financial self-interest as
well and and the thing is if you don't
if you can't tell your workers that
story then either your company is
fundamentally corrupt because that isn't
the true story it's like you're actually
working so that I can rape and pillage
the company over the next four years and
take all the value out of it and run
because you know CEOs do that from time
to time yes or you don't understand how
the company works and you can't tell the
story which means you're basically
incompetent so but well you people are
not wired up so that they will work
without knowing why unless you beat them
and then if you beat them you don't
don't be thinking that that's victory
no so the temporary victory hmm
it's that's also something really good
to know about marriage it's like you can
never win an argument with your wife
like you could if you only lived with
her for one day right it's like I won
see you later
yes like no no she's there the next day
and then she's busy remembers that she
does she does remember that yeah maybe
even more than you remember it you know
and it also might be that she was right
and you just out argued her so you know
and that's something that's really worth
knowing too because sometimes you know
you have an argument with well let's say
with your wife and she's got something
to say and it's not very well
articulated same could be true for you
so you can just brush it aside but you
don't want to brush it aside because
maybe there's something there and if you
don't address it then it's not like it's
gonna go away man it's gonna grow so
maybe you have to help her formulate her
argument which is really annoying you
know because you want to win you having
this disputes like I want to win it's
like well you're not winning that game
you're winning the game well I could
think about it as the game of games you
want to win the set of games that
stretch across time the long war yeah
that's right because I'm waiting the
long where that little battle is knock
no matter and in fact I don't you should
not try and be right if you're right
everybody knows it's fine
but there's the worst thing you do is
rub it in and see I'm right and you're
wrong
yeah yeah you do that a hundred times
and then like well you're the you're the
winner and she's the loser and then
that's great cuz now you're married to a
loser I mean you know that's if you do
that a hundred thousand times then your
marriage is over and then and then
they'll be hell to pay you can be sure
of that
I got asked the other day what is the
biggest problem in America and I thought
about it I hadn't been asked that
question lately I've been getting some
good questions a lot of times like you I
get the same questions over and over and
over again but I guess asked what's the
biggest problem in America and I thought
about it for a second and this may or
may not be right but I thought it was at
least thought-provoking I said that the
biggest problem that we have in America
is that we don't have any big problems
and if you look at us in World War two
during the Depression during times where
we've got major major problems the
country kind of unifies and it gets
behind itself and joins together and you
know I talked about you know that we we
live in a bubble here I kind of opened
up with that as well
and and that's good look I I want there
to be a bubble just like I want my
family to live in a bubble and I almost
want I almost want my daughter to really
really think it's a real problem
that there's not a strong Wi-Fi signal
in her bedroom and so sometimes it takes
longer to do like I've kind of succeeded
as a dad if that's her problem she sees
that as a problem that you know it takes
a little extra there's a there's a
longer buffering time on some of her
Netflix right I've done a good job if
that's a problem because you know God
can only imagine what kind of problems
people really have but sometimes I feel
like in America and really in the West
as a whole the problem is is that we
don't have any major problems so now
it's the Wi-Fi in our bedroom that we're
getting crazy about and and and wanting
to lash out about and I guess my point
here is that do we as individuals do we
need struggle there to keep us focused
on the right things and as a country or
as a culture do we need to have some
level of struggle before we start
looking at things that don't matter and
turning them into things that we
perceive as actually mattering yeah well
you know a couple of things about that
Kierkegaard wrote about that back in the
late 1850s thereabouts and he said there
will come a time when the best thing
that you could do for people would be to
make things more difficult right and
that's a thing because everyone's
working so hard on making things easier
there will be no come a time when when
there's a felt sense for difficulty and
I think we're at that point now and I
think that's why this message of
responsibility and truth is echoing so
nicely among particularly among young
men because every time I talk about that
in my public talks the room goes silent
and that's really interesting and you
know people are dead focused on it and
so like enough rights and freedom it's
like truth and risk time for truth and
responsibility and there's something
noble about that and we haven't been
able to talk about nobility for god only
knows how long you know so I do think
that's the case and I think it's a and
William James said that what we need is
a moral equivalent to war so something
that's as serious but that is hopefully
not as destructive and so I really like
that idea as well
so but I think that we are at that cave
at that point if people would open their
eyes a little bit because we have this
unbelievable culture this technological
culture that does provide the degree of
protection that you described that's an
ongoing miracle
right it's absolutely unbelievable that
any of this works at all and it could
easily not work and if it didn't work
there would be hell to pay
and and to keep it working and to keep
it moving forward especially with what's
going to come over the next ten years
with with with artificial intelligence
and the sorts of things that were we're
learning and inventing we better have
our acts together and so I think that
you can get that warlike sense if you
start to if you start to understand that
you can take on your life like that
that's also why I think it's so
necessary to see the world as a
battleground in some sense between good
and evil but you don't put the evil
outside like some of its outside
obviously but that's not your initial
concern your initial concern is to get
your act together right to take on the
burden of being to bear the suffering
like you said you found that when you
went out into combat that you know you
might have been weary of death which is
perfectly reasonable but that you
weren't afraid of it to the point where
it would paralyze you well that's a
useful thing to know you know because it
means that you're different than you
thought you were you know because people
are afraid of suffering and death and
especially if they've been completely
and constantly sheltered from it but you
can discover and lots of people do that
if they actually confront it that they
can tolerate it far better than they
thought I mean think about all the
people who work in like palliative care
Awards you know or in funeral parlors
for that matter like they're confronting
death on an ongoing basis and yet every
day they go to work so people are tough
and so I think there is a responsibility
that everybody can take up and I think
the responsibility is something like
well we need to decide if we're gonna
collectively and individually tilt the
world towards heaven or tilted towards
hell we saw what hell was like in the
20th century that could be back at our
doorstep in no time flat we should have
learned that and it's necessary for
people
to understand the relationship between
their individual actions and the
direction of culture as a whole you know
look at that guy in charge
Charlottesville you know that was one
guy and he probably increased
polarization in the United States by
like 5% or something you know it doesn't
take very many individual actions of
that pathological sort to tip things in
a very terrible direction so I mean one
of the things I've been telling the
people who've been watching my videos
and in the live conversations is that
you have to take yourself seriously you
have to know that you're a monster and
that you're capable of terrible things
and that it's and that you have a
responsibility to understand that to
incorporate it to constrain it and to
discipline it and then to work for the
alleviation of suffering and the
constraint of malevolence and if you
understand that then it can turn your
life into a noble enterprise and then
you have some self-respect which beats
the hell out of self-esteem in my
estimation so and I don't think that
that's a difficult message for people to
understand I think they know that at a
fundamental level and I think at the
moment they're starving to death for it
the subordinate principle so the the
thing when you talk about this elevated
state this elevated thing I I think I've
figured out that what you're talking
about is essentially truth that is that
to you sort of the what we need to do is
deal in truth on a daily basis in our
own lives and and in the lives with
people around us well I think it's two
things like in in in in in sort of
classical Christian morality and I bring
it up because it's sort of at this
substructure of Western ethics there's
two things there's truth and love and
and you know both of those words are
even hard to say because they be mouthed
to death but but they have in some sense
they have a deep technical meaning and
if you know that then it kind of
reignites their power
and love is the decision that being is
worthwhile and should and that you
should struggle to support and improve
it and that's not a trivial thing
because being is rife with suffering
you know everyone dies everyone gets
sick like it's it's brutal it's brutal
and it's easy to turn against it and so
the idea that you're going to
voluntarily accept responsibility for
that assume that it's good or act as if
it's good and try to improve it is no
trivial matter and that means you have
to scour out the resentment and the
arrogance and the deceit and primarily
and and it's sort of based on this idea
I would say is like well life is very
hard obviously but we're not doing
everything we could to make it better
and we're often doing things to make it
worse so even if it is suffering which
is true we have no idea how much we
could ameliorate that if we all put our
efforts into it and so that's a genuine
question it's like yeah there's reasons
to shake your fist and curse God I mean
everyone ends up in a situation like
that someone they love gets a terrible
illness and disintegrates before their
eyes you know maybe they're a really
good person and they've done nothing you
would think of to deserve that and you
know that terrible fate is visited upon
them it's very difficult not to get
cynical and angry under such
circumstances but then well that takes
you down a very bad road if you do that
but it doesn't it doesn't it doesn't
change the fundamental question it's
like if your life isn't everything you
think it should be you have to ask
yourself if you're doing everything you
can because you actually don't get to
make a judgement about the structure of
being until you do everything you can
and I would say that's love essentially
that's the decision and then truth is
the best the best strategy with regards
to that attainment and how could it be
otherwise like if you're going to
contend with reality you bloody well
better know what it is you know when
truth isn't your grandmother's you know
your your your two tight laced
grandmother's moral finger wagging it's
like the truth of existence is brutal
and bitter and
so to be able to face that and and to
admit to the things that you are and to
and to communicate them with other
people especially in an intimate
relationship it's like that's that's no
cowardly morality that's not the
morality of cowardice quite the contrary
you know Nietzsche said you could assess
the spirit of a man by determining how
much truth he could tolerate it's like
that's that's the right that's the right
way of thinking about truth
well you opened this whole podcast with
some truth it's like who wants to hear
that you know and people think oh that's
so terrible and they don't think well
could I be one of those Isis guys it's
like I can tell you if you're bitter
enough especially if you hate women
you know because they've rejected you
because you're such so goddamn useless
that no woman in their right mind would
look at you twice you know that'll
generate plenty of bitterness in your
soul and if you don't think that you
could act like that under those
conditions then you're not even watching
your own fantasies so truth in the
service of the betterment of being it's
something like that and that's that's
enough to give your life meaning I don't
care where you start like I had this kid
come and visit me a while back and he
had never left his home state and he was
I think he was 19 and he was over
protected and over sheltered and he was
a smart kid and so of course he also
thought that the world really hadn't
appreciated his gifts which is a very
common feeling for smart kids who who
aren't getting anywhere right they get
really angry about that and then he
decided that he was gonna move out of
his house and he took a job as a
dishwasher and he said he tried to do a
good job as a dishwasher it's like good
that's some humility it's just a
dishwashing job but you know you can be
a good dishwasher and then the
restaurant runs better and then it's
kind of fun as long as the people you're
working with they're half decent you can
make good social relationships and then
you can learn to be social which was
happening to him and then maybe they let
you be a short-order cook you know and
and you got a bit of a clue and then you
have a bit of money and you have a
little independence and it's a lot
better than being at home and being
bitter and resentful and immature
you know it's just a dishwashing job
well that's the wrong way of thinking
about it it's like it's it's the first
door that's open to you you know and
then he came up to Toronto he he never
been out of his home state so it was a
big deal for him to come to another city
when he first came to talk to me it was
outside of one of my lectures he
couldn't even speak he was so nervous
because he had pretty high levels of
social anxiety so his tongue tied and I
invited him to come over to my house to
talk to him because I knew there was
something up with him and he told me
this story you know and I thought well
you know that's the beginnings of a
heroic journey he was able to humble
himself enough so that you know if
you're low if you're in a low place it's
a low door that's gonna open and you
might think I'm too high to crawl
through that low door Young said Carl
Jung said people modern people don't see
God because they don't look low enough I
really like that idea but that's it if
you're in a low place the opportunity
that presents itself to you is going to
be low and it's gonna be very tempting
to you because you're arrogant resentful
to say well that's not good enough for
me it's like well do you have an
alternative if you don't have an
alternative then an inch up is up and
it's the right trajectory you know and
so that's humility that's humility it's
like you're low you take what you take
what's given to you and you see if you
can make it work and the thing is that
works way faster than people think
even because I worked as a dishwasher
when I was a kid you know for you for a
year or so and it was really hard to
begin with because I didn't know what I
was doing in the German chef who was
kind of a tough guy just let me flounder
around for two weeks to see if I would
quit so I was there till like 3:00 in
the morning
and I was 13 I think I couldn't wash all
these damn dishes I thought it was
impossible I told my dad at one point I
said I don't know if I can do this it's
like I'm working as hard as I can and
they keep piling up you know but I
didn't stop and then the German cook you
know who had been treating me pretty
harshly and one day he said okay I'll
show you how to do this and then he
showed me how to organize the dishes and
everything it was like that was not no
problem I could do it like 10 percent of
the time so then I cleaned up the rest
of the kitchen I had a good time mucking
about with the chefs and we played
around a lot
back there and I ended up working as a
short-order cook and I learned to cook
and all of that and that was a good part
of my adolescence but but the thing is
so the thing is is that those trivial
jobs
it's the conception of their triviality
that makes them trivial they're not
trivial not if you do them right and if
you're around people who have any sense
you know sensible people are always
looking around for other people who can
do things right and if they see you
trying to do things right the
probability that they'll open a door for
you is virtually a hundred percent
because it's kind of rare you know so
they're gonna be skeptical to begin with
to see you got to prove your mettle
let's say but as soon as you do they'll
think okay well we'll give this kid a
little bit more opportunity and see what
happens and you know to not think that's
how the world works is to be
extraordinarily cynical because that is
how it works in a functioning society
yeah I mean I work with businesses all
the time and there is they make anybody
that is just above normal competency in
anything that's gonna try any move
that's gonna put effort in they love
those people and those people are gonna
do well and you're absolutely right that
doors are absolutely gonna open for them
if they do what they're trying to do to
the best of their ability and doing a
competent job well the other thing
that's interesting is what happens to
people who aren't trying because what
happens to them is like they're in a
place where there's a thousand doors in
front of them that are invisible they
don't know the doors are there and they
could either be opened or closed and so
if they're one of these people who is
going above and beyond the call of duty
unless the organisation is entirely
corrupt right and that happens sometimes
then there are people who are watching
and they'll start to open these
invisible doors and then all of a sudden
the person has opportunities in front of
them and they don't even know why some
of the time right because someone said
you know gave a positive word to someone
else and said to all you could take a
look at this kid and so these doors open
and then the people who are in there
grudgingly
and bitterly it's like people watch that
and they're the people who are the
gatekeepers and they just closed the
doors and then the person looks up and
there's nothing in front of them there's
no open doors at all and
and then then they curse God you know
for making such a miserable cosmos it's
like no you just don't understand what
you just don't understand what happened
is like the fruits of your bitterness
that your bitterness manifested fruit
you don't even know it
you've delimited your options in a
terrible way and you've closed you know
you're you're walking down you're
walking between cliff walls and they're
getting closer and closer and closer
together and then you'll be stuck and
you'll think how the hell did this
happen and it happened because you
didn't you didn't avail yourself of the
opportunities that presented themselves
to you so you know that's horrible but
that's that's how it is I get asked a
quite often you know this guy got
promoted and I should have gotten
promoted what should I do now or this
person isn't carrying their load and and
they're they think I should do their
work what should I do now and you know
the answers yeah someone wants to do
that work do their work I'll do that all
day long yeah don't kid yeah you you you
don't want to do your job that's fine oh
yeah
and actually I got I just answered a
question where somebody said today the
guy's a friend of mine and he's not
carrying his load what should I do and I
said well how about you help him what's
going on at home is he going through a
divorce is he got issues is a kid sick
how much you help them and say hey let
me let me take that off your plate right
now because it two months or six months
you might be the person that needs help
you might be the person with a sick
child but regardless that maybe he's
just as lazy and maybe he shouldn't be
your friend and maybe eventually he
won't be your friend but nonetheless the
solution is the same if you don't want
to do your work that's fine I'll be
happy that that's such a funny thing
that's exactly right because you know
what you want to do in your job is make
yourself indispensable right in the way
you make yourself indispensable is by
being indispensable and the way you do
that is by doing a bunch of things that
if they're not done catastrophe occurs
and that's exactly right so if there's
someone around you and they're
abdicating you're their responsibility
and you can pick it up it's like what an
opportunity you know it's you think well
I'm not going to get credit for it it's
like
well first of all there's lots of
different forms of credit but you learn
and then when the company shrinks and
they're looking at who to keep you know
they think oh it turns out you're doing
all sorts of so we can't do without you
that's not what we expected we can't do
without you
here's some more things you could do you
know and then you're also in a position
to bargain you can say well look you
know in order for me to keep doing this
level of responsibility you know I need
to be paid more because I have other
options or because it's just or because
that will make me more efficient but
then you've got some power to because
they need you and so indispensability
and that's power indispensability is
power not tyranny so now um obviously we
started off talking about some very
negative stuff with with Isis and and
you've touched on this a little bit
already but I I want to make sure we hit
this hard enough and that is for people
to to live a better life to live a life
that they're proud of to live a life
that they that that when they die they
don't regret the life that they lived
and for me I mean I I tell people
discipline equals freedom that the hard
work the doing the right thing you know
I tell people to write down what you're
supposed to do the next day before you
go to bed and then you wake up and you
do the things that you're supposed to do
the things that you said you were
supposed to do the things that you
actually know are going to make you
healthier and faster and smarter and
stronger and and make you more money and
and move you forward and help your
family you just write those things down
and then you go do them and and that's
essentially you've drawn that out on a
large scale with and you've described
this somewhat with the experiment that
you did with with people writing down
what they're supposed to do not just
tomorrow but what their life that's the
future authoring program and that's
that's really been immensely beneficial
for you it certainly seems to have been
um it's at self authoring calm and we
put up
discount code for your for your
listeners it's willing and so they can
get 20% off it and it this system allows
you to write an autobiography and to
analyze your personality flaws and
virtues and to write a future plan and
you can do all of those are one of them
but yeah it's it's extremely useful
because one of the things you can be
virtually certain of in life is that you
don't get something you don't aim at and
one of the things that's interesting
about that is often people will keep
their goals fuzzy because the one of the
problems with specifying your goals is
you specify your failures right if the
goal is really fuzzy you're not sure
when you fail and that then you can fool
yourself you know really but you can
kind of keep it foggy but you make your
goal sharp and clear then well first of
all then you know what to aim at and
what's interesting is you know your
brain is set up so that it reorganizes
the world around your aims and that's
not I've also written about this in 12
rules for life it quite extensively and
that's not a metaphor like we don't see
much of the world because there's a lot
of the world and there isn't much of us
and so we see what we aim at we aim with
our eyes and here's an example so a
great apes don't really have much of a
white in their eyes but human beings do
and the reason for that is that we've
evolved to detect where everyone else is
looking and so if I can't tell where
you're looking I don't know what you're
up to
and then well over time that means I
can't read you as well and more we're
more likely to get in a dispute and one
or the other of us is more likely to get
killed but it also means that your your
probability of findings as successful
mate decreases so we've evolved to have
this very very visually evident eye and
so when we're looking at each other
we're always looking at our our eyes
because then we can tell where someone
is pointed and then we can tell what
they're up to
and so we're hunting creatures like
we're aiming at a moving target and
trying to track it all the time and so
you have to specify your aim and the
future authoring program helps people
specify their aim and it's more than one
aim it's like you have a highest aim
which you might say is to be a good
person
and then I would say well there's a
there's a more elaborated aim than that
it's like you want to be able to
constrain malevolence and work to
decrease suffering it's something like
that that's the highest aim and and then
and then you have to decompose that into
the things you do each day so that
there's a definite connection between
all the micro actions and the macro aim
and then that gives dignity to what
you're doing you know so you know if
you're racing at home with your kids
what are you trying to do well you're
trying to raise them to be the kind of
moral agents that will work to constrain
the evil in the world and to reduce
suffering it's like and so that's what
you're doing when you're changing a
diaper if you're doing it carefully and
with some respect and some love like
it's a major-league deal to be doing
that and god only knows who your kids
gonna be you know he could be the kid
that shoots up Columbine or could be
Stalin that wouldn't be so good or he
could be someone or she could be someone
who is a positive benefit to the world
you know and so every child is a whole
new realm of possibilities and so
there's dignity in that if you
understand that so the future authoring
program anyways helps people lay out a
plan and I always suggest to people that
they do it badly because you're not
gonna do it perfectly and if you get
perfectionistic it's going to stop you
you know when you first start to plan
you're probably only going to be about
20% right but zero the difference
between zero and 20% is immense and we
found with our research that even people
who only spend an hour on it benefits
substantially in their ability to stick
to what their next plan is know and you
now you mentioned something earlier too
just just a bit ago yes about about
scheduling yeah so one of the things I
tell people so you say write down what
you're gonna do the next day before you
go to bed that's good because then you
you've got a direction set when you wake
up in the morning hey so but I've told
people to learn to use a schedule and
people often hate schedules because they
act as their own tyrants right they say
we have to do this unpleasant thing and
then here's another unpleasant thing you
have to do and then you have to do this
unpleasant thing and you do that for
about three days and you think tell with
this I'm not
you know and you fall off the wagon that
isn't what you're supposed to do with
the schedule you're supposed to use it
to design the days that you would like
to have if you were taking care of
yourself and so some of that is you know
you wake up in the morning and you think
here's five things I have to do that if
I don't do my life will be worse it's
like paying bills for example or taking
out the garbage it's like you have to do
those because otherwise things
degenerate so you got to put some of
those in the schedule because otherwise
tomorrow is worse than today and that's
a bad trajectory but you also want to
build in things you know you gotta act
in some sense like you're dealing with a
relatively recalcitrant nine year old
it's like so well here are some things
you have to do but here's some things
that if you do you could reward yourself
with and if you get the balance there
between obligation and reward right then
you'll find that you're motivated to do
the things and and that's what you want
to do you want to do that so it's
sustainable across days and weeks and
months and so you got to you got to
treat yourself like a good boss would
treat a valued employee and not like a
tyrant would treat a slave because the
slave will rebel and you know people say
well I don't follow through on my plans
it's like well eh they're probably not
very well formulated and maybe you're
doing them because of an external moral
obligation or something not really your
plans right and be you're acting like a
tyrant and a slave and that's a bad
relationship to have with yourself
so you you want to treat yourself with
some well the same way that's the Golden
Rule write it treat yourself as you
would treat other people as you would
have them sorry treat other people as
you would like to be treated it works
both ways you also treat yourself like
you treat other people properly so
that's a necessary thing and often
people don't do that
but the scheduling is really important
yeah actually I when I tell people
because when I first started talking
about this people would start scheduling
their day and they were just go you know
minute by minute and everything would
become something you can't maintain that
for multiple reasons number one is no
one wants to have a day like
where everything that you do throughout
the day minute-to-minute sucks it's
things that you don't want to do so
guess what after three days you said I'm
not doing this anymore it's it sucks
it's not fun and and so and the same
thing with the task list people would
push those off if they're not on the
schedule so yeah it's they put it on the
schedule but then the thing I ended up
telling people is you need to you need
to number one schedule empty space in
there where because things are gonna
take longer and then you're gonna be off
schedule and then you'll be frustrated
so you schedule that things are gonna be
just empty you're not gonna do anything
for for this hour before lunch
you don't schedule anything you're not
gonna do anything not gonna do anything
there and the other thing is you
schedule things that you actually want
to do in there and then you go and
execute the things that you want to do
you want to work out every day you know
you should well maybe you'd maybe if
it's something you enjoy then you
schedule it in there if you enjoy going
picking your kids up from school on
Tuesdays and Thursdays because that's
when they do the running club then you
schedule that in there so you can go and
do that thing that you want to do so you
don't just schedule the things that suck
you schedule the good things too and
discipline equals freedom I say this all
the time if you want to have more free
time which is what people want then you
need to have more discipline time man
it's been eat you will end up with more
free time I promise you I promise you
you will the other thing I was thinking
about and I I couldn't I just kind of
occurred to me now is people always tell
people you know come up with a goal and
then write it down and then you're gonna
get there and I was you know as you were
talking about future authoring what
she'd said earlier when you were
describing the program in its infancy
what became future authoring is I was
saying well how do you get people to
actually do this well what you've
embedded in the program is the fear of
what happens if you don't do these
things and where you're gonna end up and
people forget that people forget where
they end up if they don't do what
they're supposed to do in life and I've
explained this to to my kids that when
you look around and you see people that
are doing things which are
self-evidently not desirable things to
be doing in life whether you're a bum or
whether you're doing uh you know I was a
dishwasher as well and I have an
interesting story about that no I'll
tell that at some point about a Scottish
girl named Roslyn she was older than me
I was 13 and after you know several
weeks of washing dishes and she was a
maybe 17
Dean and and anyways to make a long
story short eventually I said hey do you
won't want to like go to a movie or
something with me because I'd like to go
to a movie with you and she looked at me
and she said Jocko you have a serious
mental problem
so Roslyn I know you're out there
somewhere you broke my heart sister but
I wash dishes and that's a good thing
for a 13 year old to do but when you're
18 okay now it's a little bit you want
to have moved up to be the short-order
cook and by the time you're 25 you want
to be in charge of the whole kitchen and
by the time you're 30 you want to maybe
run the nighttime shift and and that's a
good progression and that's good but you
don't want to be 35 and 40 40 years old
out at the dishwashing stage you don't
want to be there and I explained to my
kids because you can see people that are
at that stage in their life and sure
there's a chance that maybe they had
some hardship that came along that that
that hit them and it put them in this
position and now they have to build back
up again and they're waiting for those
windows of our back doors of opportunity
to open up and that's okay but a lot of
times it's because they didn't work they
didn't make good decisions they didn't
do the best job that they could and so
they end up in these positions that they
shouldn't be in and it's and I tell my
kids that those are real people that
that are in those positions like we're
gonna leave this restaurant and we're
gonna go home we're gonna do what we do
that guy is gonna be there for five more
hours cuz it's nine o'clock he's gonna
clean everything when they get know he's
gonna be there for five more hours then
he's got him up before and you know what
he's doing tomorrow the same thing he
was doing after that the same thing it's
a real person and I hope it's a fourteen
year old I hope it's a sixteen year old
I hope it's even an eighteen year old
but I hope it's not a 48 year old but
there are 48 year olds that end up in
that position and what you do in this
program is you you explain that you can
end up there and actually being a 48
year old dishwasher is actually pretty
positive too to wear some ocaña
Oh
definitely which is addicted to drugs
addicted to alcohol or or or whatever
well and everybody kind of has a sense
of where they would end up if they let
things go down you know and everybody
has their their specific weaknesses that
that their faults would exploit you know
and some people would end up homeless
and some people would end up with a
physical illness or a psychiatric
illness and some people would end up
addicted and some people wouldn't end up
cruel but everybody kind of knows where
they would head because they've seen it
they've seen it rise up and it's really
useful to be terrified of that as if
it's a possibility you know that's a
heaven and hell' thing essentially it's
like okay but even as if it's a
possibility it's a possibility it's an
absolute yeah yeah well and all you have
to do to get there is do nothing I kill
just drift there all by yourself so not
only is it a possibility it's actually
rather high possibility and so you have
to make that realistic enough which
means that you have to take an inventory
of your weaknesses let's say you have to
make that realistically enough so you're
actually terrified of it because then
that's a great motivation and in my
clinical practice people are often faced
with tough decisions like well you know
I'm not happy at my job and I'm afraid
to leave it just look fair enough you
know that's a big deal
okay how afraid are you of not leaving
it let's lay that out because you know
one of the peculiarities of human
thought is that you do get used to the
devil you know and then you you downplay
it but it's very often that's staying in
the same place will do you in it's much
worse than the risk that you'll take you
know what I mean I'm practical with us
to say look if you're gonna stop your
job let's let's have a clue about this
right get your CV together right start
seeing what other options you have
because you don't want to just step off
a cliff that's not helpful
organize yourself so that you've got
enough strength to go through the
process of finding a new job you know
you're gonna have to get used to be an
interview do you want to think that
through maybe we can practice that so
you got to set yourself up for it but
you really want to think through the
cost of inaction
and that's something people generally
don't do and this is also one of the
useful features of having a tragic view
of life let's say because most of the
time often you're screwed either way
but you get to pick which one and that's
a big deal it's like there's there's
risks on both paths and their major
risks and that's actually freeing
because you know well there's trouble
both ways
so that frees you up because if you
think well this is the safe path and
this is the dangerous path well then
you're not going to take the dangerous
path but if you think well I've got
danger a or danger B and this is where I
would rather bet my future well that's
way better and I've had like many many
clients that I've helped with their
careers and we do exactly that it's like
you know okay what's our goal our goal
is to triple your salary in four years
they think well that's not possible it's
like well we'll try four doubling but
you don't know it's possible you got a
let's get it together and you're going
to get over being afraid of looking for
a job you go to get over being afraid of
being interviewed you have to put
yourself together so that you've you've
got options and then you got to start to
push you don't know you might be able to
do it well it's it's it's quite
surprising how frequently that works you
know and that assumes the people are
trying right they're competent you know
it's not this isn't waving a magic wand
or anything like that and it takes a lot
of work you know like if you're gonna
switch jobs you might have to I figure
fifty to one failure to success it's
something like that and it's useful to
know the baselines as well right because
looking for a job is can be very
disheartening unless you know the
baselines it's like well yeah fifty and
fifty resumes for one interview don't
take it personally it's just how it is
so it's not that your us screw up it's
that there are way more resumes than
there are jobs and and that can also and
then you know don't look for a job for
eight hours a day because you only be
able to do that for three days and then
you'll die you look for a job an hour a
day if you already have one for an hour
a day or half an hour a day for three
months two resumes a day three resumes a
day you'll find a job it'll take a while
one of my clients took like three years
you know to get her first
but then right after that she got
another one and then right after that
she got another one but she stuck it out
and you know it was brutal because she
had interviews and they didn't go you
know they was she working in a job that
she didn't like at the time yeah but I
also say the people like you know
generally stay in your job because
you're way more likely to get a new job
when you have a job so I always tell
people yeah because I get the same exact
thing hey I'm in this job it's miserable
I don't like it want to leave tomorrow
but I don't have the courage and I've
said actually it's gonna take you more
courage to stay in your current job
formulate an exit strategy save up money
start putting together a better resume
get some technical skills that you might
not have right now do all that while
you're suffering in this job that you
don't like so that when you make the
transition which will come it'll be the
right way and you won't end up like you
said jumping off of a cliff well it also
makes you hopeful even in the terrible
job because you know then you've got
some hope and like hope is a big deal
you can you can put up with a lot of
misery if you've got hope but if you
think I'm miserable today and I'm gonna
be miserable tomorrow and next year I'm
gonna be older and just as miserable
it's like that's that's not good but if
you think well I've got a plan you know
that's that's a whole different story
yeah and it's a good idea for those
veterans that are out there don't just
get out formulate a plan figure out
where you're gonna go and have that in
place and then you get out you step into
yeah well I'd really like to see the
military use this future authoring
program for for people who are
decommissioning because you need you
know your idea that you need the next
mission is that that's exactly right you
know life is like a series of missions
forward you know and nested in something
greater than that I think but you you do
you need to have a plan and you know
it's you got to kind of hold the plan
loosely you know so because you're gonna
make mistakes formulating it but the way
it works basically is aim at something
in the future and so then you start
moving forward and as you move forward
you accrue more experience and more
information sometimes that's through
failure doesn't
matter but you're not staying in the
same place so you're actually growing
even if you're even if you're doing
badly if you learn from those mistakes
and so then you move towards the goal
and your perspective shifts and then you
might have to modify the goal a bit
because now you're a little smarter you
think well that other goal wasn't
helpful it's like yes it was because it
moved you an inch farther ahead and so
you know you kind of approach the final
goal in a zigzag manner and the zigs and
the Zags get less extreme as you get
closer to the final goal but you have to
do a lot of zigzagging to begin with so
you got to give yourself that space for
error that's why there's an archetypal
idea mm-hmm that the fool is the
precursor to the Savior which is a
really and you see that with comedians
yeah comedians are fools and they tell
the truth right so so in the court
jester is the only person who gets to
tell the truth and a fool will take a
risk as well and you need to take risks
in order to progress so that's the idea
but it also means that you have to allow
yourself to make the mistakes that are
necessary while you progress and not
beat yourself to death about it and so
that's also really helpful because it
means that when you're formulating your
plans you can say well this is the best
I can do now subject to revision it's
like great that's good enough really
it's good enough it just has to move you
to the next place that's interesting
because you know obviously I've done a
ton of military planning and I would see
guys that would get so wrapped around
trying to make the perfect plan and it
would take them so long to plan that by
the time they're ready to actually eat
the plan for the whole target had
shifted and things had moved in the
battlefield to change they're not ready
to do this anymore so you need to come
up with a plan like you said you need to
come up without good idea of what you're
gonna do and how you're gonna do it and
then you start to move and and and as
you move you start to see things from a
different angle and you gain more
intelligence and you get another report
and all the sudden the target shifts a
little bit but you're adapting and
you're closer to the target anyways very
vigorously yeah is that well and it is
it's also the idea that you're gaining
information because you might say well I
don't know what to do with my life so
maybe I should just stay here and figure
it out it's like no no if you stay there
then all you know is what you know well
you're there and you don't know enough
because you can't make a plan so make a
bad plan even if even if it's actually a
that works out so that its opposite of
what you want if you move towards that
plant you're going to know more clearly
that it's opposite of what you want and
as soon as you know that it's opposite
you know oh I should be going in the
other direction so like that's that's
not that's not a retreat that's that's
an advance and and the thing is people
we're active creatures and we're always
navigating through territory right we
can't be sitting in one place and
waiting well you can't because you get
old
so you even if you're sitting in one
place the place is changing on you and
that's just what you said that when you
said you know people make a detailed
plan and then the environmental shift on
them and on future offering yeah
do you go back in and adjust your goals
yeah as so it's a it's a it's something
that you continually update yeah and I
would say don't update it too often
right because then you end up in the
situation you were just describing but
the idea would probably it's something
like make your damn plan implement it
for four months or six months and then
go back and see what needs to be updated
you know and you'll find that you've
done a lot of what you said you would
and so then it'll need to be
reformulated so and and that's also very
self affirming I suppose is the right it
helps you understand that there's more
to you than you think which is actually
the case you know there is more to
people than they think that that's one
thing that's interesting about human
beings and so you can put yourself you
can you can stand up to things you're
afraid of you know in measured doses and
you find that you grow to be larger than
the thing that you're afraid of and you
know that's like that's like one of the
basic rules of clinical therapy is like
if people are afraid of something you
break it down into pieces and you have
them encounter the things they're afraid
of and they don't get less afraid they
get braver and more competent which is
way better because there's plenty of
things to be afraid of so so once again
here's just a total alignment
I wrote this kid's book it's called way
the world okay I read it okay so I
didn't know about this but I knew what I
did with my kids and in the book you
know the kids scared of water and he has
not a swim so he starts off wading in
the water and then he eventually dunks
his head in the water and then
eventually
he covers up to his neck in the water
and then eventually he swims a little
bit and then he finally jumps off the
bridge but that that's when I heard you
describing that process in some
interview that you were on or one of
your podcasts I said I put that in my
book you never know it aggressive
exposure and so what you want to do what
you want to do is you can do this for
yourself you think okay here's something
I'm afraid of doing okay and so I won't
do it because I'm actually afraid of
it's okay fine decompose it like let's
say you're afraid to go on a subway you
have Agra phobia it's like okay all
right go online and look at a bunch of
pictures of a subway can you do that go
to the subway station and look at the
subway station and then go home or go
into the subway station and open the
doors and go in and then go home but
don't don't play tricks on yourself
right if you say that you're gonna go
and just look then just go and look and
then go home you know because otherwise
you won't trust yourself the next time
you do it so you have to keep the
bargain intact but and what you want to
do is you want to push yourself a little
farther than you want to go but so that
you would go that's all you have to do
and that's that's kind of a rule for for
learning in life so this happens the
reason it works is because this is
actually how human beings learn and so
if you watch a kid maybe let's say a kid
that's a little inhibited because some
kids will just take off will use the
kids it's a little inhibited so they're
around their mom and they're in the
playground and there's strange kids
there maybe they're like four years old
something like that and so they're
thinking about maybe that that they'll
go out and play and so they hang around
mom for a while and they check out the
situation and then they'll go out a
little bit and check it out a bit more
and then they come back and maybe they
need a little patch or something like
that you know because they're coming
back to home territory and then the next
time they go out a little farther then
they'll come back and then next time
they go out a little farther and then
they'll come back because they want to
know they can come back and they're
checking to see how far out they can go
and if you're patient and encouraging
even with kids that are quite nervous
you know you encourage them to - to keep
going out and exploring then they'll
habituate and well what they do is learn
they're competent and away they go and
so it's not surprising
that graduated exposure works because
that is actually how human beings
learned to confront the world but it's a
great technique yeah and the story in
the book wasn't my daughter was had
stage fright but she wanted to be in the
School Musical and so it was started
with her in her room singing by herself
but I was outside the door with the door
shut
yeah and then it was okay you saying
what the door is opening this happened
over you know a couple of weeks yeah now
now the door is open now I'm gonna stand
in the doorway now mom and I are gonna
stand in the doorway now we're actually
becoming and sit down and watch you sing
and then it was the family's gonna watch
you sing and then the neighbors are
gonna come watch you sing and eventually
she has no no issues whatsoever right
now a very confident kid but that was
yeah that's perfect I translated it into
the water for the story for whatever
reason but yeah yeah well that also
means that see what I like about that
story too is that you established an
individual relationship with your
daughter
you know because kids have different
temperaments so like some kids if you
take them to the playground it's like
they're like pup you put them down on
the ground they're like puppies over
water they're hit feet we'll be going
before they hit the ground and they're
just gone right they're out there
playing with the kids
those are extroverted kids who don't
have very high levels of negative
emotion and your problem is going to be
that they'll run off too far you know so
but then other kids are more they're
more inhibited and often they're a
little more introverted they're a little
higher negative emotion so then what you
want to do is calibrate and you have to
watch it's like okay how much can this
kid tolerate it's like we'll push it and
you can you can figure that out it's
like it it has to be you have to push
them enough so that if they accomplish
it they feel that that's an
accomplishment it can't be too easy but
it can't be too hard you want to put
them right on that edge that's the edge
between order and chaos right
fundamentally you want to put them on
that edge and let them experience what
it's like to be there then they also
learned that they can be there because
you know you taught her two things you
taught her that she could sing in front
of a group but you also taught her that
she could learn to do something she was
afraid of doing and that's a way better
lesson right that's a killer lesson so
so that's good that that means and you
can do that with kids - with graduated
reward like you can watch them and if
they do something well I'll tell you how
I did this
my daughter so my daughter had arthritis
and it was really bad and she had to
learn to give herself and in while she
had taken Jackson's every day and so and
I think that started when she was like
seven and so we could give her the
injections but she was pretty skittish
about that and no wonder cuz they hurt
and everything so I thought all right
tell with this we'll we'll get her to do
her own injections and so I sat her down
and I said she was pretty motivated by
money she's always been kind of a
capitalist kid day so we found her
outside once when she was four selling
all her child books on the street which
was quite funny I think she was maybe
five but whatever I said look kiddo I'm
gonna give you this needle and if you
can give you if you can inject this
yourself in 45 minutes I'll give you 50
bucks and so I let her sit and she like
struggled with that she struggled with
that a and but by about thirty minutes
she did it and I thought that could work
math good work so then the next time I
said okay this time it's thirty bucks
but you got ten minutes to do it and so
she did it and you know soon we got it
down so that because I wanted to get it
down so there was no hesitation right
because actually the anticipatory
anxiety is worse than the needle so you
want to push it so it's like okay now
and we got to the point where it was if
you can do it in five seconds I'll give
you ten bucks and so she got to the
point took about a week where she could
do it in five seconds and I kept paying
her because well for obvious reasons you
know I mean it was kind of unfortunate
she was very sick and she had these
needles and we had to do some things
that would sort of perk her up you know
to some degree but that was a hard thing
for a kid to learn you know it's not an
easy thing to give yourself a needle but
you can use that graduated exposure and
careful reward you can get kids to do
very brave things and then they also
learn how tough they are it's like hike
and she was proud of that man you know
she that she could go and do it by
herself because that was a big deal it
also gave her some control over here
illness yeah so competence that's what
you want instill in your kids unless
you're jealous of them
so now you also talked about you started
talking about some various personality
traits and how those come through and
you just released what a month ago a new
program understand yourself understand
myself
first of all myself calm yeah and I also
put up a discount code for your people
for that too so it's willing again and
it's twenty percent its that would make
it about seven ninety five so it's
pretty cheap what you do is it you
answer hundred questions the questions
are pretty standard like they've been
derived from the standard scientific
literature partly from a test that I
designed that my students designed about
in two thousand seven Colin DeYoung
who's now a professor at the University
of Minnesota and we we we statistically
analyzed this question set so we could
break out five major personality traits
and those are the standard traits that
psychologists believe are reliable and
valid and they've been working on that
since about 1960 and so that's
extraversion and that's it can break it
breaks into two aspects so extroverted
people are assertive and enthusiastic
it's the positive emotion dimension
they're talkative and they like to be in
social groups they like to plan parties
they like they like to talk and they're
smiley and so forth and then there's a
negative emotion dimension neuroticism
and people who are high in neuroticism
are that can be broken into withdrawal
and volatility and people who withdraw
have a lot of anticipatory anxiety so
they might shy away from doing something
and volatile people are kind of touchy
you know they're easily set off so
agreeableness agreeable people are
compassionate and polite and
disagreeable people are tough and blunt
and so women are higher and
agreeableness than men and they're
higher and negative emotion as well
conscientiousness which is the best
long-term predictor of life success
after intelligence conscientious people
are dutiful and so they're industrious
and orderly and orderliness is a good
predictor of conservative political
philosophy by the way our political
affiliation along with lo the last
dimension is openness and open people
are interested in ideas
that's intellect and creative and we
call that open its openness to
experiences the main trade and the
creativity trade is oh is openness
proper so this report gives you a
comparative description so you compared
to other people on all five of those
dimensions plus all of those ten aspects
and that can help you understand who you
are and that's very useful because one
of the things you want to do in life is
figure out what your temperament is so
that you can find a niche in the economy
or in the social world that you're
suited to so like if you're an introvert
well computer programming is not a bad
idea or accounting or something like
that but if you're extroverted you've
got to be out with people you know and
if you're high and negative emotion
you're gonna want a job that's not too
stressful and it's fairly secure and if
you're open then you're not repeating
with people and if you're disagreeable
you should be working with things and so
anyways the reports detail all of that
and so then once people see where they
fall out they can kind of put themselves
into a better position like you said a
job that suits them and that's gonna be
yeah yeah well that's well that's it you
know it's you you you do have a
temperament and there is a place for
each temperament in the economy in the
world because otherwise they wouldn't
exist and so the issue is what is your
temperament so if you're high in
openness you need you need to engage in
something creative because you won't be
healthy if you don't because it's like a
major if you're like a tree with
different trunks it's like that's one of
the trunks it might be the major one you
can't let that thing die because it'll
take a big part of it with you and if
you're disagreeable say you're a
competitive type and so you're gonna
need some of that in your life and if
your conscientiousness if you're
conscientious that's a really good
predictor of military performance by the
way then you need routine and you need
to be you need to be locked on to some
task you know because otherwise you'll
you'll consume yourself with guilt so so
it's very important to understand who
you are in that way and it's also
important that's interesting because
that's I can tell you that
that's sort of the middle of the bell
curve and even like towards the higher
end of the bell curve of military
performers are you know people that are
can concentrate on the task they're
going to be relatively obedient but when
you get to either end either high end
but either the low end of bad performers
but also the high end or the people that
know when to break the rules that are
slightly rebellious right that will
repel like that will tell you know one
of the big ones you know I don't want to
be surrounded by people that are telling
me that I'm right all the time I don't
want my subordinates I don't have people
that are working for me that are gonna
when I say go charge that machine-gun
nest they say okay and they go do it you
might think that that's what I want and
that might be the the overall perception
of people in the military I want a robot
that's gonna follow my orders I actually
don't if I tell you to go charge that
machine-gun nest and it's not and it's
gonna get you and your men killed I
actually want you to say hey joko that
doesn't sound like a good plan to me
let's do something else let's come
around to the flank so so it's
interesting that yeah you'll be good in
that middle part and you might even get
towards the higher end but the guys that
are really valuable in the military are
the guys that also have that openness
and that creativity and or and at the
same time are able to discipline it and
harness it's right they can conform when
they need to right well and they need to
be which I actually had to do as I got
older the older when I first got in you
know I was the guy pushing the envelope
I long hair and so everything that I
could do would maxed out to to stay
within the bounds of what we were
supposed to be doing and and then as I
got older I realize like oh that stuff's
not important what's important is that
you're able to do your job good and you
have creativity not with how you have
your stupid haircut but in how you come
up with a mission plan right that's
where I expressed my creativity not
through not through pushing the envelope
of uniform standards which is which is
what a lot of immature young military
guys do right right well and the thing
about the people who will stand up and
tell you what they think is that they
tend to be disagreeable types as well
and you know you hear a lot about
emotional intelligence in the business
world these days but emotional
intelligence is really indistinguishable
from trait agreeableness and so
agreeable people are polite and
compassionate and that's great
especially if you're taking care
people but you want some disagreeable
people around because they'll tell you
what they think and their blunt well
there isn't emotional intelligence
though can't you be agreeable but not be
able to read I was think of it as me
being able to read people like I
understand oh that person's got that's
going on that's their agenda is in the
background so even though I might be
agreeable but I'm also understanding
where you're coming from well I think
that's what emotional intelligence is if
it's anything valid but the tests the
tests that tend to correlate very highly
with agreeableness and so actually
agreeable managers don't make better bit
managers disagreeable managers make
better managers well they have to be
conscientious as well because a
disagreeable person who's conscientious
is actually relatively easy to work for
because they'll tell you what they think
but they'll do what they say you know
and they can make tough decisions and
you often have to make decisions that
are somewhat harsh in order to move
things ahead in the long term right
because if you're soft it means you'll
sacrifice the the long term for the
short term and if you're tough but but
have your head screwed on straight it
means you'll make tough decisions in the
present that might ruffle feathers and
hurt people's feelings but they make the
medium to long term better and so no
that's that's absolutely true I see all
the time especially with younger
companies they go through that expansion
phase and all of a sudden they got if
they go through the retraction phase and
they gotta fire people yeah and and they
wait because the the leader is too
agreeable and too soft and so they wait
and all of a sudden they're upside down
financially and it's a real problem
whereas if they would have been
aggressive and said you know what here's
the decision we got to make I know it's
gonna hurt right now but long-term it's
gonna be good for us we got to get rid
of this division or this department or
these people and if they don't have the
ability to do that it really hurts them
yeah yeah well that's the sacrifice of
the future for the present and that's
generally a bad idea the other thing
with the understand myself system is
that you can also use it too like if if
you do the program and get your results
and someone else does someone you're
close to say you can compare them and
that's really useful because you think
you understand people but you don't
understand them as well as you think so
for example my daughter was fairly well
she was quite ill so it was complicated
but
she was touchy let's say when she was a
teenager and I thought it was because
she was rebellious but she did the
personality test and my son by contrast
was very easy to get along with but then
we had them do the personality test and
it turned out she was very high in
agreeableness and compassion but also
pretty high a negative emotion whereas
he was the opposite he was very
disagreeable but very low and negative
emotions so he wasn't easy to you long
with he just never got upset but if he
ever tried to get him to do something he
didn't want to do that was like
impossible and he was like that from the
time he was 2 years old whereas my
daughter it wasn't rebellious Ness it
was that she was easily made anxious and
upset and so I learned at least two
somewhat so if she if she sort of flared
up instead of interpreting that as as
rebellious Nisour conflict I just saw it
as nervousness and that helped a lot you
know it didn't make me able to deal with
it a hundred percent but it helped a lot
it was quite shocking to me because you
know I thought I knew my kids and and I
did I think but that was very useful and
then it was really funny because then as
she started to date she had every
boyfriend she ever went out with take
the personality test first so I thought
that was that actually worked out quite
well well the thing is you know you want
to be not are the boys not smart enough
to like manipulate the answers well they
don't necessarily know what she wants I
would at least assume like okay I'm
gonna try and sound agreeable and I'm
gonna try I remember I had to take
psychological yes to uh and this was in
the 90s they gave us once you'd think
they had some big battery of
psychological examinations and
interviews to get in the SEAL Teams know
took a look one test during boot camp
and it was funny because I was really
hungry when I was in boot camp because
the food sucks and and I just thought
man I want to pass this test and I knew
I had some things in my brain that
weren't gonna be smiled upon by whatever
analyst was gonna read these things so
for any was complete dissent these are
the things I remember is complete the
sentence so it said for instance I hate
when my mom and you fill in the blank
and obviously it's real easy to go
sideways on that effect right if you're
a psychopath
but for me every answer that I gave was
you know for me it was I hate when my
mom doesn't cook enough noodles with the
spaghetti everything I gave was just
about food the rest I thought I was a
food psychopath we were getting nothing
out of me nothing I think the test that
my daughter used was one I had designed
that people couldn't fake so it wasn't
quite as accurate with regards to the
individual personality traits but it was
it was more difficult to fake good on
which is better for hiring people for
example what kind of question can you
not fake in well are you hard-working or
are you easy to get along with right are
you creative or disciplined oh right
right exactly are you neurotic and
anxious or are you inhibited and and now
can you awkward with people can you go
in between is it a 1 to 10 it's
either/or yeah with that with that
particular pairing it is and then you've
paired all these questions and
eventually you get that's right
something that's right well or maybe
here's 10 negative statements which 5
apply to you most people hate those
particularly but they're quite accurate
so we used those for personnel selection
for a while so for me it would be are
you agreeable or disciplined hungry yeah
now before we close that you you also
have the book maps of meaning yeah and
and for those people that were expecting
me to do the book maps of meaning on
this podcast and review it in depth
there is literally no reason because you
have already done that online on YouTube
and on your podcast you go through in
great detail better detail than I would
have been able to in one podcast because
you have a series of podcasts about maps
of meaning it's fascinating it's awesome
everything that you kind of touched on
today is in there in great depth and you
know there's many worshippers of Marduk
out there now thanks to you and and I'm
sure that will expand and if you want to
get into that the book is called maps of
meaning the architecture of belief it's
very interesting I also like that you
have though you talk about some of your
clients as
which by the way I didn't talk about you
at all in the opening I realized that
about halfway through this podcast that
I didn't actually explain who you were
so is there anything you need to say
about yourself that I should have said I
mean what well there's just the bare
basics just clinical psychologists I've
practiced for about two and a half
decades I've done a lot of business
consulting as well as clinical work I'm
a professor at the University of Toronto
in psychology and I might domains of
expertise are personality assessment and
neuroscience and the study of belief
systems like religious belief systems
and and I that's basically there and I
have a family I'm married and have been
for just about 30 years and I've got two
kids and a new grandchild and so that's
and I've become somewhat notorious on
YouTube over the last year really quite
bizarre trip you might say okay so
everyone can go and explore that yeah
you're pretty um I guess the other thing
I should say cuz my publicist will be on
my case if I don't as that I have
another book coming out which is much
more straightforward read maps of
meeting which is quite a technical book
and that book is going to be called 12
rules for life yeah an antidote to chaos
yeah and it's available for pre-order on
Amazon already so January 23rd that's
whoa yeah and I'm hoping that now that
one maybe you come back on here and we
could talk a little bit about that book
that'd be good that would be that would
be good that book will be right up I
mean you've touched on it a little bit
you've mentioned a couple of the twelve
rules yeah today I think you mentioned
two of the tools today and that would be
awesome to have you come back on and
again I think people after they hear
this if they didn't already know who you
are they'll they'll go and research who
you are they're gonna want to get that
book yeah that'd be great to have you
back on there and then obviously you've
got your own podcast yeah the Jordan B
Peterson podcast yes
you've got your YouTube channel yeah
Jordan Jordan Jordan Peterson videos
leaders in and Jordan Peterson clips yes
you just put out yes Sekou wasn't that
you know crafty to come out with a thing
was
poor thing two channels yeah see he's
got to jazz he's the one that's supposed
to make the clips yeah well one of the
things that's been so strange
I mean learning to use YouTube people
have been clipping my work like mad
which is not something I expected like I
would say right now there's probably 40
new clips a day being put on by people
which is really good you know I mean
I've got no problem with that at all but
I thought I might as well see what would
happen if we also did it and so I put my
my my son's fiancee on that and my
daughter as well so they've been doing
that clipping and so but yeah it's cool
that the YouTube videos are so
interesting as well as the podcasts
because people can can do their own
thing with them to some degree you know
now it can be bad depending on how they
do the editing but so far my people have
been responding very positively to what
I've been doing which is quite a shock
to me but I think it I think it you've
made reference to this as well in in the
fact that you found an a ready audience
is like people are ready for a message
that's not all freedom and and rights
you know it's like Jesus enough of that
like really seriously we've been walking
down that road for 60 years it's time to
look at the alternative ethics and
responsibility that's a big one and
especially when it is the case that you
know you think freedom gives your life
more meaning that's true if you're under
a tyranny but if you're not then its
responsibility that gives your life
meaning and you you your life has to
have meaning it has negative meaning
whether you want it or not you choose
whether or not it has positive meaning
and you choose that by adopting
responsibility and so and like there's a
ready market for that because we've
we've ignored that reality for too long
so we don't say are now at the point
where they realize that being free free
free free isn't getting them anywhere
yeah well I always think it's like you
know okay you want to be free alright
I'll take you out drop you in the middle
of the ocean it's like you can swim in
any direction
it's like that's not helpful you know
you you got to be swim and be different
if I drop you near and
Island and said well swim to that like
yeah I can do that that's that's got
meaning I won't drown I won't die but
too much there's no difference between
too much freedom and chaos right and you
drown in chaos you need the right
balance of freedom and order and and and
discipline well as you said or also
which is a paradoxical thing the more
discipline you have the more
self-discipline the more freedom
even-even putting in those hour breaks
that you described you know sometimes
when I've been too busy which has been
fairly frequent I'll take an hour break
you know and I can actually have a break
because I've done the things that I was
supposed to do and so even though it's
an hour long I can actually relax during
that hour not being plagued by my
conscience there aren't things undone
you know and so that's that's that's a
really good thing to be able to attain
when you feel that you've got things
you've got the right things reasonably
under control and you're moving uphill
that's better than anything else really
yeah speaking of getting things under
control echo yeah maybe could you tell
people quickly how they could support
this podcast if I don't feel like we
keep talking about what we've been
talking actually have a question two
questions okay you know so with the
recent kind of saying everyone waits for
in the podcast you know with the rise of
your exposure will call it do people
kind of flock to your class now
well no not so much to my class but
they're definitely flocking to public
talks yeah yeah so and and and my class
is generally been quite popular you know
so those so and make sense yeah and and
I'm on sabbatical this year so we'll see
what happens when I when I returned was
that luck or did you pre coordinate that
well it was actually the grace good
grace of the university you know because
well I had to get my act back together
after all these things happened you know
and I've also had some health problems
over the last year that had been rather
severe which I think I have under
control maybe
but I told them that look I'm gonna be
much better if I take this year and and
do what's necessary for this book that's
coming out and wreak inception alized
what I'm going to be teaching because
the other thing is I have to do that
I've got all these lectures recorded now
they're on YouTube it's like it isn't
obvious to me why I should do them again
I've done like there's three years of
some of them online so I have to re I
have to rethink what I'm doing as a
university lecturer because with YouTube
you know you can do something new like
this biblical series that I've been
doing you can do something new and you
can have it out in front of a hundred
and fifty thousand people in one day
it's like well you got to think about
that that's a whole different universe
and I like doing lectures on things that
I'm I'm still learning about it's hard
to do that at university because you
have to have the evaluation structure
people have to know what to expect and
you know it has to be pre-planned and
that's not so good if you want to do
something that's novel so I've got a lot
of thinking about that and I don't know
what's gonna happen this next year in
any case so you find that like um like
let's say you did a talk about something
specific and people saw it online I
think a lot of times people are more
compelled to see that same one in person
like a concert you know like oh yeah I
listen to ZZ Top and you know I have the
CD or whatever but they're in town for a
concert or they're you know in the next
state for a concert I want to go see the
concert well I think I I think that that
works out okay for me because there are
these underlying themes that that
permeate everything that I'm saying and
yeah I would say those are the
archetypal themes so I have this sort of
structured way of presenting information
that's based on well the work I did for
maps of meaning and so even if the
lectures new there's echoes of the of
the other ones always I mean one of the
things about archetypal stories is that
an images is that they're very expansive
you know and so they're multifaceted and
so you end up touching on the same
themes over and over but from different
perspectives you know and one of the
things people tell me all the time which
is really interesting and this is really
being the case for 30 years as they come
up to me after the lecture and they
you know you were telling me things that
I already knew but I didn't know I knew
them yeah and that's that's definitely
an archetypal experience because you
know your your experience does have a
certain structure and that doesn't mean
you can say what it is but if you hear
it being said then you know that's what
it is
yeah and so it's fun in front of a crowd
because I can watch that happen to
people they because I'm always speaking
to individuals within the crowd and I'll
say something and a little bit of the
jerk back a little bit I think yes so
that just clicked a couple of years
together for you just really well it's
fun I get the same thing so with with
extreme ownership the book and you know
it's about leadership principles and we
say in the book these are not new these
have been around for hundreds and in
some cases thousands of years of how
militaries run organizations and
therefore the military leadership
principles are actually the same as all
leadership principles cuz you're trying
to get a bunch of crazy human beings to
do something that's gonna behind a
mission and execute it in the most
efficient way but people say oh you know
I kind of always I always thought that I
should do that I always I've always done
that yeah but but yeah you captured it
yeah and and it's a self-awareness I
think when people they maybe they do
have good natural leadership judgment
and they've always taken responsibility
for things and but they never really
thought about it they just kind of did
it well then once they know hey I need
to take ownership of things well then
then they really can do it yeah and they
also see it in their subordinate
leadership and they go that guy's not
taking ownership of things they're not
doing a good job and it's the same thing
with keeping things simple or
decentralized to command or prioritize
next week these are things that
successful leaders do prioritize and
execute if you get a leader that's gonna
try and accomplish 37 different things
at the same time they're not gonna be
successful so so leaders they know to
prioritize and execute good leaders but
when we say it to them you know they
might still they might not do 37 things
but they might do try and do eight
things at the same time and they know
that they should be doing one or two
yeah and when when they hear us say and
describe the Gulf yeah that's why yeah
well one of the things that
characterizes leaders that he or she
knows where they're going right I mean
that's that's that's the fundamental
print
yeah Billy communicated too but that's I
worked for a UN Committee at one point
economic sustainability economic and
environmental sustainability and one of
the problems with the first draft of the
report and I would say the final draft
to some degree is that you know it was
all done by committees so there are a
hundred priorities it's like no there
aren't a hundred priorities that's a
contradiction in terms
it's like you start with one of these
things and maybe you start with a small
piece of it and see if it works but it's
to have a hundred priorities is to make
no one dissatisfied but you're not going
to you're not going to move because you
can't move in a hundred directions at
the same time so it's a real abdication
of and and people do that in a sneaky
way too because they're abdicating their
responsibilities right say well we're
going to move in a hundred directions
and and everyone had input it's like
well that's not the issue the issue is
how you condense that down to an actual
action plan and that actually makes you
accountable that's the thing and that's
why people don't do it it's like well if
you're going 100 directions and it's
hard to see whether you're you're doing
it well but if you go into one direction
that doesn't work it's like well that's
pretty obvious so people are afraid to
do that but if you don't do it it's
failure yeah
I get the same thing where I get people
now they ask me a question and I give
them the answer next I know you're gonna
say he does that's also how you're
talking about kind of breaking the loop
in your behavior like oh I want to make
a change to that one thing you know to
break glue and then you start with
something small and then it ends up
affecting more thing
and you mentioned sometimes it's hard
because you don't get Pat's on the back
for those little things you know yeah
well they're often so small they're
humiliating that you even have to do
that yeah yeah but in a lot of time like
to yourself it's like kind of big like
um like oh I'm gonna drink eight glasses
of water a day now you know and then
it's almost like you're seeking that pat
on the back like you want to tell your
friend like eh I drink eight eight glass
of water now and they're just like yeah
so yeah right and you're like why do i
party use gonna like why do i even do it
then if no one's gonna care you know
well you know there's a lesson to be
drawn from that too in terms of
relationships that's really useful
psychologically is and this is a big
mistake that people won't make it's like
if you want to have a good long term
relationship with someone then you watch
them constantly and when they do
something that you like you let them
know yeah even if it's a small thing
yeah because they're way more likely to
do it again you know and so sometimes a
personal have kind of an inkling about
what they might do that's good or that
would be good for your relationship with
you or that might even just be pleasing
to you but they won't say anything
they're like afraid because maybe they
won't get attention for it and but then
they do it and you notice it's like man
that's super powerful like you have to
be really attentive though because the
good things that people do don't stand
out the mistakes they make a stand out
and then you say well you made a mistake
it's like yeah yeah but to watch and to
reward someone for doing something small
right that's that's a step in the right
direction
yeah he's a killer strategy I found that
to be true with my daughter she's four
and a half now oh yeah some kids really
are tough and they don't respond to
punishment at all yeah you just can't
you can't you can't you can't intimidate
them my daughter if I just pointed at
her she would stop huh but my son it was
like that was just round one it just
laughs he just laughs and run away so
but he responded to reward like mad if I
watched him and he did something that
was good and I told him that it was like
he was just yeah yes so that's good yeah
yeah it's reward is harder to use but
it's more effective if you come an Ajith
yeah and then that's not like kind of
how you say where you're like be careful
with the reward when you give like too
much reward for these small things you
know and then they can think that's
problem with the self-esteem movement
you know oh yeah every every kid gets a
trophy day ya know it's like inflating
the currency if everything is good then
nothing is good because their house
there has to be a distinction so yeah
you want to watch and you want to see
when the person's made an effort and you
want to see when they've gone beyond the
call of duty and then you want to say
hey I noticed that that was really good
yeah and yeah and it is scarcity really
matters in those situations because
otherwise it just turns into no
yeah yeah yeah patronizing noise even
which is even worse it's like oh you're
doing well really well it's like leave
me alone yeah yeah it's such a lie yeah
I have a fun time with that actually
I'll be like um if I have to judge and
go all through my kids lives if I had to
judge them and their friends and I have
three daughters in one son
usually it was the daughters I was being
some kind of a judge I'm gonna judge the
dance I'm gonna judge the little play
that they put together I'm gonna judge
the acrobatic routine that they're doing
in the backyard and always be judging
these things and I would have so much
fun because I would say they do their
little performance their 1 minute
performance and they'd come out table
how was it
and I'd say okay first of all
presentation overall I'm giving you a
four point two I didn't see one smile
until you actually got on stage that's
wrong and I would just go through and
give them this really strong critique
yeah and and they loved it yeah they
loved it damn [ __ ] mad they would be
happy to didn't it go try to go try that
raise that four point three to a four
point five baby smiles like you could
see them a mile away oh yeah yeah I just
got that I was at a pool party with a
bunch of little kids running around and
I ended up judging the diving
competition and all the parents were
watching and and they were aghast at
what I was doing yeah that wasn't my
house by the way oh I did it there - no
I do it already this is what I did it at
your house - right yeah you've seen it
in action yeah I give the kids a little
Nate names and then and then I say you
know you were completely unbalanced when
you left the board it was almost
embarrassing for me to watch you go try
it again I'm giving you a two point -
yeah go try it again and see if you can
bump that up a little bit yeah and the
kids get almost up there now yeah yeah
but - do you have treated them like
someone who could improve right so
that's a big deal that's that's better
than that's better than a pat on the
back it's like because everyone's flawed
and everyone needs to improve well so
when my kids were little I taught them
how to speak in public it took about an
hour that was it so I have them they had
to read
something you know and so they'd read it
and I was across the room and say well
that that's not loud enough it's like I
can't hear you it's like belted out and
they get a little louder it's no no no
that is what I mean
read it way louder than you think you
should and so they did that I said lots
about right because there's nothing more
appalling than listening to some speaker
that you can't hear it's like there's
just no excuse for that then like make
it clearer put some passion into it you
know and it was was unbelievable how
quickly they would pick that up you know
and and that also made me sad because
because it took so little time to get
them to do that and then they had it you
know
and so and that that like a critic is
your best friend if the critic isn't
destructive because if what a critic
does is say look you did ten things and
like these five things you need some
work on those they're not good and
here's some things you could do that
would make them better and here's two
things that you got all right and here's
three things that you did pretty well
out and so then well what's the message
the message is hey you can handle some
actual criticism so you're not some
little you know useless wimpy thing
that's gonna die just because someone
isn't telling you that you're already
wonderful plus you're not already what
not nearly as wonderful as you could get
so let's keep that in mind and then you
know you lay out a pathway for
improvement and then you treat the kid
with some respect and and you also show
that being an adult means that you know
more than being a kid because you know
the kid does something you say oh that
was really good it's like what are you
saying well as an adult I don't know any
better than you do and that's pretty
dismal message because the kid is going
to be an adult for a very long time and
one of the things we do really badly in
our culture is model why being an adult
is better than being a child because it
is better you have freedom and you have
responsibility and you have autonomy and
so we're always so concerned about
making our kids feel good about
themselves it's like they should be feel
good about becoming responsible adults
because they're gonna be adults for like
80 years and they're gonna be kids for
like 20 years so the adults the goal so
yeah that was interesting when you
started doing that because the kids are
like seven years old and under but yeah
yeah and he's like letting them have it
but you it's funny you have this kind of
tone about you though when you talk to
kids that it's like it's almost like
live that much over theatrical just that
much so you can tell he's like playing a
character right right right and the kids
love it it's so funny my daughter like
loves him and the kids are just
scrambling around wanting to do it again
and like let me do this let me do that
your daughter's all used to it you she's
like okay okay sure that's so funny so
funny kids though you know big jock
ordering these kids love attention
yeah it's their currency and yeah they
want attention because adults actually
know more than they do
and so if you pay careful attention like
I get along really well with little kids
and it's because I pay attention to them
and if they do something good then we
had this kid over at our house once this
is a sad story I told it in my new book
so this kid was boat for a really cute
kid really nice-looking kid and his
nanny had been hurt in a car accident so
he was kind of being shuffled around the
neighborhood for daycare for like a week
or so away and I'd heard some not some
rumors about this kid and so I was kind
of curious and so anyways he came over
to our house my wife was also taken care
of some other kids at this time and I
came home and he was standing the other
kids were playing in the like living
room and he was standing in the porch
sort of in the corner you know kind of
just wandering around back and forth and
I looked at him and I thought that's not
so good so I kind of poked him a bit you
know and I was poking him and trying to
get him to play and he had this like
really mask of a face on unhappy and I
poked him in he kind of jerk away and
all that and I couldn't get him to smile
I couldn't get him to play it I thought
that's not good that's not good because
he's four like I he should have you know
acted unhappy for two or three pokes and
then kind of laughed and then we would
kind of get into it you know so so that
that wasn't so good so then we had lunch
and the rule at our house was eat your
damn lunch and say thank you to the
person who made it because otherwise
they'll cook you horrible things and and
you'll die so so it's like it's hard to
cook lunch for you have some gratitude
you little monsters and so you ate what
what was there and so his mother when
she dropped him off said he probably
won't eat anything all day but that's
alright and we thought well actually no
that's not alright because he needs to
eat and and it's and it's not alright
that he doesn't eat wrong and so we'd
learned how to feed recalcitrant
children by that point and so all the
kids were at the table and they were
eating and my wife had made some chicken
stew and he wasn't eating and so she was
trying to feed him and so we were
watching him very carefully and so she
bring up the spoon to his mouth and he
like move his head back and forth you
know to refuse it and it was just like
about a nine month old would do that eh
when you're trying to that's their their
first trick and so that's a nine month
old trick and we thought okay well
something happened when he was nine
months old and he never really got
beyond that and so you know my wife was
fairly persistent with the spoon and
he'd get annoyed and you know squawk a
bit and she'd put some food in and then
he'd swallow it and then and then as
soon as he took a little bit of food
even and she powdered him and tell him
that he was being a good kid and she
meant today it was not a game like she
was really intent on getting this kid to
have lunch and so that's fine and he's
moving his his head back and forth but
what was cool as she kept patting him on
the head and telling me was good kid he
was opening his mouth more often even
though he was still moving his head back
and forth and so it took about ten
minutes or so and she'd fed him the
whole bowl of chicken stew and she said
she showed him he said look you're a
good boy you ate all of it and that
horrible mask that he was wearing you
know that mask of unhappiness it just
fell off him and he had this great smile
it was just it just made the hair on the
back of my neck stand up because you
could see that was the first damn thing
that he had been allowed to succeed at
you know and so he was thrilled and then
for the rest of the day he followed my
wife around like a puppy dog like he was
one step behind her and then we went
downstairs into the basement and we were
watching TV and he climbed a
her lap and he grabbed onto her just
like there's this famous experiment that
Harlow did with monkeys and the monkeys
could either have the wire mother that
fed them milk or the cuddly mother that
they could claim to they were both
artificial and that monkeys preferred
the cuddly mother you know and that's
what it was like he was just wrapped
around her you know and then his mother
came home and she came downstairs and
she took one look at this kid wrapped
around my wife and she said Oh super mom
and grabbed him and you know walked out
and I thought you that was horrible that
was a horrible thing to see because he
wasn't one day with that kid you'd fix
him up huh you know it was one positive
experience was enough to bring him out
of his shell and you know it's okay that
he doesn't eat it's okay that he stands
in the corner doesn't play with the
other kids you know it's okay that he's
miserable and unhappy it's like hey
guess what that's not okay it's not even
a little bit okay so that's a good
example of the use of reward you know it
just it was something to see I'll tell
you yeah well speaking of breaking the
loops we'll talk about origin so Origin
American made stuff Jocko has his own
line of supplements so in the event of
your joints because that's really the
main one mmm your joints yeah
Jocko super krill krill oil better than
fish oil by the way mm-hmm
what do you make of this when someone K
so krill oil back in the day my wife's
dad my father-in-law used to always say
take krill oil for your joints it's good
and he's one of these like health for
lack of better term health nuts
right I don't know if that's good or bad
but and he'd be like yeah krill oil it's
even even better than fish so I'm like
cool never listen never listen but then
when Jocko for some reason takes doesn't
even say to take it just like he takes
it then I start taking it and I reap the
benefits of course cuz krill oil is dope
but what do you make of that what if the
krill oil do for you just it helped so
you know how you get joint just from
working out and doing stuff you know
joints get sore especially when you get
older whatever in my experience
um so I started taking krill oil and
here's the example I said it before um
I'll try to make it quick so my daughter
she was 4 she's maybe 3 at the time 3
something um and in the morning how
she'd wake me up is she'd wake me up and
then when I get up she'd jump on my back
kind of she wouldn't let me walk down
stairs without her on my back so when
she'd do that
you mean you just woke up you're not
warm you may or may not have you know
worked out did some training whatever so
you kind of got an exercise like perfect
form to stand up with this little girl
who's moving on you're on your back
because otherwise you get injured so
after it was about six days of taking
krill oil I didn't have to like it was
like I was already warm that was the
feeling that's cool but why do I listen
to Jocko and take krill oil and not my
father-in-law well he's telling me the
same stuff you know often having an
example instead of being told is more
effective you know when there's a
confidence I think that goes along with
someone doing something and not telling
you about it yeah yeah you've been
psychologically unwound well nonetheless
so on top of that jock wise his own
krill oil so you know that's the good
one super krill not just regular super
by the way also joint warfare which is a
bunch of other ingredient is that
glucosamine chondroitin yeah yeah you
got the perfect formula for joint
sustainable joint maintenance and health
perfection that's from origin origin lab
so origin mancom on the top menu labs
boom that's where you get it is there
like a I think there's like anyway
there's a link on the story anyway there
needs to be link on our store there is
yeah there has raised boom right there
whatever you need also G's and rash
guards if you're introduced to introduce
you to Jordan Peterson I'm not Brazilian
Jujitsu been afraid not there's not much
call for that as a professor videos
where you might have wanted yeah
in your back pocket yeah yeah well we've
got one coming up on November 11th to
talk on free speech and I'm afraid
there's gonna be plenty of trouble at it
I hope not and security
I got crews yeah boom there you go
nonetheless if you are introduced to
think of some good keys american-made by
the way for what you know if you're into
the american-made some actually I was
born in Canada by the way where Victoria
British Columbia
hmm yeah but I moved back to Hawaii when
I was like two months old it was a kind
my mom lived in Hawaii shoes from Canada
go back home to have the kids between
brothers still have us two months later
bone doctor so is that kind of deal so
you don't have many memories of Victoria
there no fraid not only the pictures but
I've been back feet I've been to
Victoria and Toronto actually and
where's Rory where's over than the East
Coast for film anyway no I was where did
they speak French a lot way way over
there on the east coast
well country yeah yeah I don't know why
I can yeah I'm not sure it was good
that's really nice yeah Mon trails a
great city yeah Rory MacDonald was with
anyway back to the keys and rash guards
um we got I ate so much at some
restaurants a guy car was up there for
UFC my fighter cut weight and then it's
time to go reload Montrell yeah Mon yeah
and we ended up at this little Italian
restaurant and it was insane how the guy
was making the noodles he made
everything everything he made himself
and then we get done I'm you know just
completely gluttonously filled with food
and uni comes out would you like some
dessert and I was like not anymore and
he says it's the best tiramisu in the
world and I have a yes off the preferred
fur for tiramisu yeah and and he brought
it out he made it and it took him 20
minutes to make and he brought it out
and it was the best thing that I ever
put in my mouth
it was so good pretty delicious and
Montreal has excellent rest
I wish I remembered the name of the
place I'd go back there yeah but I don't
actually did find that money we went to
a diner it was just a diner and you it
seemed like it was the same thing like
they put Carrie and everything all the
fries or what I liked it was [ __ ] yeah I
like Atlanta by the way yeah yeah man
it's good nonetheless rash guards we do
have some new ones coming out from
origin and we have our own new ones
coming out but Pete over there at origin
he makes warrior Kid the rash guards are
coming out yeah yeah that's gonna be on
the store though which I'll talk about
in a little bit okay good store by the
way also fitness gears or fitness gear
if you want to break the loop I think
that's the theme that's what i'ma leave
you with one of the many things by the
way I'm gonna leave here wit break the
loop so you know people they want to get
more in back into their fitness or
improve their current fitness they want
to try kettlebells it can be
intimidating I'm speaking I'm speaking
from experience but break the loop just
get one kettlebell I think you should
get the chimp kettlebell they're decent
you know a kettlebell right we did talk
about Chimpy today yeah that's one of me
I'm gaining all that all the themes so
you get these kettlebells on it it's the
company called on it on it calm slash
jock oh by the way you can get these
kettlebells when they're not just a
cannonball with a handle
they're like a cannonball shape like a
chimp or a werewolf
they're pretty dumb anyway on accom /
chuckle check those out and break the
loop man get it get one get two I think
I have like eight now legit also
self-proclaimed legit saying I'm legit
for doing it even though I am but that's
not what I'm saying
okay I'm saying sounds like you proclaim
yourself as legit did so make that
disclaimer that's not what I'm that's
not the point the point is my set of
kettlebells is legit chimp
double chimp werewolf double werewolf
gorilla double Gura these are go at
escalation in weights and one big foot
90 pounds
what's your heaviest one ages
no man ah two pounds heavier every rep -
but where's the legit part yeah every
rep though every cent every rep two more
pounds boom over time that is legit also
when you get maps of meaning by dr.
Jordan B Peterson I'll list it on the
website
talk about Cass comma listed on that
website books click through there that's
a good way to support and they do break
Gemini and twelve rules for life yeah oh
yeah you can pre-order that one yes yes
yes yeah it's doing pretty well in
pre-order yeah it sold about 4000 copies
in pre-orders nice pool yeah hey yeah
yes II will double that number when this
podcast comes out I'd be good
that'd be good the cool there so yeah
man if you wanted people that what's
cool is people that listen this podcast
they read we read books all the time
yeah they read the books they buy the
books that's it's it's awesome oh well I
should say too then I have a book list
on my website on Jordan B Peterson car
okay yeah it's a book of recommended
readings and so if you want to well I
mean the books that had a huge impact on
me well ordinary man is right ordinary
men is one of them from The Rape of
Nanking as well yeah which is a we did a
podcast a movie yeah a lot of man you
would be very interested in the
follow-on book to that which is called a
woman who cared too much which is
written by iris Chang's mom right right
yeah I know iris committed suicide yeah
yeah well no wonder after investigating
that and being harassed for it's not
surprising yeah and it seemed like her
mom thought it was a lot to do with the
drugs she'd been prescribed and going on
and off drugs and apparently you should
just stop taking one drug and start on
some other drug apparently she was there
she was being directed to do that and it
was negatively impactful at least
according to what her mom thought so
what a what a travesty that was yeah I'm
sure that the your book list and our
book list is probably has a lot of
overlap so it's like basically all the
books you were talking about we already
covered no like you already covered that
I'm not saying that but you know like
we're familiar with it because it's on
the same list yeah a lot of overlap but
yeah well I've looked at your list and
it is actually not a lot of over
there's a I mean you obviously have a
ton of books on there that that a lot of
people would be interested in reading
that I haven't covered in yeah so yeah
perhaps me will do some of them actually
yeah so yeah but yeah well these are
gonna be on that list again go to jakka
podcast.com on the top little tab it
says books from the episodes and I got
it listed by episode sometimes multiple
books per episode by the way so yeah go
through there that's a good way to
support click through there and get
those books from Amazon and if we can do
other amazon shopping Hey
carry on do that too good way to support
also subscribe to the podcast if you
haven't already seems obvious I know but
if you haven't boom subscribed a good
way to support also on YouTube like we
talked about we only have one channel
Jordan B Peterson s2 that's good maybe a
good idea though because they go to
certain channels for certain things yeah
you know I mean well it's not obvious to
what the optimal length of a YouTube
video is you know different links serve
different functions
yeah and different experts will give you
different answers with that hmm very
interesting hey do you ever listen you
know how you you mentioned that people
get your you're like little clips of
your talks and they'll make their own
videos you put some music on there you
know they do that with a lot they'd
obviously they do that you ever like go
on there and just kind of watch them and
be like hey I never really really felt
it like that you know with that it music
arrow it's really interesting just let
people do with it you make just watch
mine yeah that's fine
that good we made her head this little
thing about this the expression good so
I was like all right let me let me make
a video made one of those made him watch
it but he liked it somebody made a video
where they put me through one of those
gadgets that auto-tune yeah yeah I was
talking about cats and rats and so it's
like this sort of rap video five hundred
thousand views so you know me my brother
retweeted something that I was telling I
go about this you retweet you retweeted
it's some it's some computer sorting
something sort of numbers yeah and it
you can just
watch this thing sort yeah and you
posted two or three of them and I
watched the all three and it's just kind
of funny that how did we get to a place
where we're watching a computer sort
things and it's well first of all why is
that on YouTube in the first place and
I'm sitting there watching and I'm a
person that that constantly tells people
don't waste your time on YouTube videos
and there I was watching you know three
45 second YouTube videos of numbers
being sorted they're great like that
well yeah we like to see things being
sorted yeah we're like you ever seen
those big domino patterns you know yeah
that they've met and they just have a
video of it and you're just watching the
Domino pattern you know it's kind of the
same thing well we've actually actually
I feel bad now we failed to talk about
sort yourself out today we didn't even
use the word sort until right now that's
a real that's a real mistake on my part
yeah for those of you that well you'll
find this as you get into Jordans work
you'll see that he talks about sorting
yourself out and he'll that's what you
need to do is sort yourself out yes
that's become that's become I mean my
guess you can buy it on t-shirts and all
sorts of things so that and clean your
room yes yeah which is I really think
that's so funny it's so it's so absurd
so much of what's happened in the last
year is being surreal and absurd but
that's certainly one of them you want to
talk about absurd the other day I was
had my daughter cleaning her room and I
was playing a judge on Peterson clip of
you telling people she's getting so mad
at him but I thought it was fun and then
and then she told me yesterday that she
had had a conversation with her friends
about torturous things and mean things
that their parents had done and that is
what she's following
oh yeah I can understand that
I can I can understand that but those
YouTube clips a lot like how you say um
they made the rap video right yeah so a
lot unlike me my brother would always
start he'd always say that what people
do when they add the music to your voice
it almost gives it like this um you know
like when this might be a crude
comparison but you know how like dogs
you got to give them their medicine but
you got to put in the food you know so
it's kind of that you know like okay you
know this University of Toronto
professor I get it
maybe other people might not get it cuz
it's just this quote/unquote boring
lecture but let me put some cool music
behind it yeah well and I think people
are doing that because they do find
something you know they find a statement
or two that hits them and you know yes
then they like to play with it and as
far as I'm concerned like more power to
them it's really interesting to see how
that multiplies out you know it's it's
been fascinating to watch that I'm a
degree into an artist a rap artists made
a song the song is called to free and
it's a guy rapping and I forget his name
right now I apologize but he's rapping
and then the song like his rapping fades
out and uh in comes me talking about
discipline equals freedom in the middle
of his rap song it's it's like the last
minute of his rap song thing and I was
going back and forth with him on Twitter
and he said yeah man I really dug what
you said I heard it on JRE yeah yeah so
you're like a rapper well no he's a
rapper too though no you guys both are
straight-up rap artist rapper poet
author that's legit yeah nonetheless
YouTube that's a good way to support
subscribe you know chaco podcast the
legitimate jockle podcast though because
there could be fake accounts I remember
there were Oh
but yeah yeah YouTube channel that's
what yeah actually it's not very hard to
distinguish at this point nonetheless
good way to subscribe also Jaco is the
store it's called Jacko's store that's a
cool name right it is it is it's also
like direct right right to the point
the whole deal yeah man just like just
like the name of
I have the Jordan B Peterson partner
real creative yeah you scored high and
openness a boat yeah but it is a legit
store nonetheless I'm still a basic
store but what we got on there got some
shirts some rash guards for jiu-jitsu
and surfing actually for pretty much any
physical activity cycling whatever um
also some women's stuff on there and
hats hoodies are out mmm for the winter
yeah see he's from Canada you need to
legit yeah me too
he's from Hawaii yeah he's not he's from
Hawaii and last hoodies that he made
were thinner than your shirt that you're
wearing right now they're inappropriate
as hoodies so he beefed it up again this
year slight exaggeration but true
nonetheless so yeah they're they're
thicker hoodies for sure and they're in
some patches on there again some women's
stuff for you you know the lady troopers
gin after it um so yeah she'd be all
good on there uh some new stuff coming
out I'm gonna let you guys wait on what
those things are
ooh anyway let's just go store calm
that's a good bike it's this big thing
you know there's four people that are
waiting I'm just saying that's the one
talking to boom
anyway that's called your coaster calm
easy to remember also okay so
psychological warfare tell you what that
is makes sense too so when you're on the
path that's what we're calling it right
the path mm-hmm yeah discipline right
don't you know I like okay I'm gonna
take you got to keep doing that stuff
you know you can't just be like I'm
gonna quit drinking and then just quit
drinking for one day you got to do it
for four good but some days you find
that it's like hard like would say I'm
gonna wake up 4:30 in the morning every
morning now for the rest of my life one
day it's gonna be like I can't do hit
snooze but now psychological warfare
it's an album with tracks you can get on
iTunes whatever and each track is for
each little weakness that might come up
see I'm saying so let's say you're about
to wake up you want to hit the snooze
instead of the snooze psychological
warfare
get up and get after it that's the name
of the track it'll have Jocko telling
you pragmatic
why you shouldn't do that why you should
stay strong stay on it stay on the path
you campaign against weakness and also
you know it goes for a bunch of stuff
like you want to skip the workout that
day or you're procrastinating you know
and I'll leave it for tomorrow
whatever create a block all that stuff
anyway it's called psychological warfare
check it out see if the it see if any
one or more of the tracks addresses your
potential weakness on your path that's
what it's for and that by the way that
that album was the number one spoken
word album for something like nine
months and it was only recently and this
is on iTunes it was only recently
overtaken by another album that's called
the discipline equals freedom Field
Manual what is version audio version
which is now on iTunes and Amazon music
and Google Play and other did you read
it yes you did yes yeah cuz I've been
thinking about reading my book oh you
absolutely should I read this yeah I
read this with my buddy life and this
book the kids book way the warrior kid
my son read oh yeah he read the kid and
I read uncle Jake so I have fun with
that kind of thing
also when you're in Amazon you can get
John a white tea which you may want to
try it do you ever dead lift weights
yeah okay this will give you a minimum
deadlift of 8,000 pounds of white tea it
will get you there 100% also on Amazon
obviously we got the books Jordans books
maps of meaning and 12 rules for life
pre-order it the thing that this is
what's gonna happen and I had to warn
people that was gonna happen and it's
gonna happen to your book to your
publisher doesn't understand what's
happening they don't understand YouTube
they don't understand your podcast they
don't understand this podcast that
understand Joe Rogan's podcast and
understand that and so they're printing
books and they think oh yeah we think
it's gonna do okay the book is gonna
sell out so people don't pre-order the
book
they won't get there's two things first
of all they won't get it when it comes
out and second of all they won't get the
first edition copy which is kind of like
if you're a book guy you want that thing
if you want it to be first edition okay
that's so if you want his book which you
do preorder it and do it now way the
warrior kid if you want to put your kid
if you want to sort your kid out and put
them on the proper path the proper path
get them booked way the warrior kid you
said you read it yeah okay yeah it's
funny I use that term to in my in my
book the proper path my editor asked me
quite repetitively I'd say what exactly
what I meant by that but it's you know
sort of implicit in the book but proper
is the right word for that for some
reason it's even though it's a kind of
an old word in some ways old-fashioned
word that's okay there's a lot of
old-fashioned words that we could put
that we could use again I agree and I
wrote this book because all the books
that were out there for kids we're
telling them that there was okay to be
weak and that it was okay to do bad in
school yeah maybe they weren't smart
enough to to know their times tables and
all these some maybe it's okay if you're
scared of the water maybe should just
stay away from the water they took no no
no and no right do you want okay you
want yeah it's not okay to be like that
yeah
it's but it is okay to be strong and it
is okay to study hard and work hard it
is okay to face your fears yeah it's
okay to stand up to the bully it's okay
to do those things it's proper to do yes
that's right that's right well that's
the problem with that damn self-esteem
movement it's like you know they what
you're supposed to be telling kids is
that who you are is more important who
you could be is more important than who
you are because you're living it's like
what are you living for you're you know
if you're already everything you should
be it's like well you know you're done
so what good is it growing up that's not
helpful it's like you say look man
you're full of potential there's those
worlds out there to conquer there's
things to do there's people to help
there's things to put right get the hell
together get it together and don't let
your fears stop you as opposed to
everything is great and you're you're
you're this wonderful child why would
you want to then burden yourself with a
bunch of responsibility why would you do
that doesn't make any sense I'm already
good to go yeah
no unburden me oh and the kids no that's
not true because they're not like and
while people in general know this
because they're not satisfied with their
life they have a feeling that there's
got to be more well there is more but
the more isn't by radical
self-acceptance of all your pathetic
flaws extreme ownership another book you
can get it's about personal
responsibility and how that will make
you win as a leader so get that book if
you don't have it yet and if you don't
have if you have it and you want your
team to be better get the book for your
team so that they start taking ownership
for the problems and and then the
problems start getting solved discipline
equals freedom Field Manual it's out
thanks to everyone that bought it and
made it into a best-seller a New York
Times best seller a Wall Street Journal
bestseller those things are cool
guess what appreciate it appreciate all
you out there buying the book spreading
a word all everyone that sent pictures
of 12 books stacked up that you're
buying for everyone on your team or
everyone you know or you're buying them
for Christmas and your dad and your
uncle thank you for doing that
because not only to help the book do
well and continue to help the book do
well it's also going to help those
people out in my opinion okay not that
everyone's gonna get it some people are
gonna go this book is stupid impossible
you know yeah and what we talked about
earlier some people read the book and
they go I already knew that well of
course you did but why didn't you do it
yeah why didn't you do it because
someone obviously thinks you need to do
it so okay you get it that's fine yeah
you know what you're supposed to do
guess what we all know we're supposed to
do we all know what's gonna improve our
station in life and what's gonna make it
worse why aren't you doing the things
that you're supposed to do question I
don't know now you get a man you
actually do it you want to know why
could you lack the discipline you lack
the discipline to do the things you know
you're supposed to do don't know you
might also lack the fear it's like it
actually matters if you don't do it you
know matters if you leave things undone
you leave the world in an uncompleted
state
it hurts it hurts you it hurts your
family it hurts your society and it
hurts the world so if you're laying
there being useless and not getting at
it then you're contributing to the
catastrophe and it's that simple so it
actually matters if you do it and I
think sometimes people don't do it
because they don't understand that you
know they're they're down on themselves
they don't think they matter it's like
you matter a lot more than you think you
you do and actually that's rather
frightening you know because you think
well wouldn't it be nice if everybody
mattered it's like you got to think that
through if what you do matters you
better look out
so get at it because you're gonna pay
for it if you don't know thank you yes I
obviously agree that and and a lot of
people been asking for the audio version
and like I said it's on the mp3
platforms it's on Google Play iTunes
Amazon move music Spotify yes Spotify I
think you can ask your Alexa to play it
right if you have that digital thing in
your yeah that if it's on Amazon music I
think it automatically does this I don't
know for sure but if you need some
leadership support training at your team
or your business a chillon front that is
the leadership consulting company it's
me Lafe babban JP Danelle Dave Burke
info at Ashkelon font calm we'll come
and get after it with you and your
leadership team if you want to keep this
conversation going you can hit all of us
up on the interwebs on Twitter Instagram
and on the face bulky echo is that echo
Charles I am at Jocko willing and Jordan
is Jordan B Peterson on Twitter
Jordan B Peterson on YouTube and dr.
Jordan B Peterson on Facebook and like I
said you also have the podcast as well
echo do you have any clothing for the
closing thoughts that's it thank you so
much hey thanks for the invitation it's
been great yeah looks like we're doing
the same thing from different directions
so that's and not so different even so
that's pretty cool so yeah it's good
anything else from you nope don't think
so appreciate it
we'll get you back on here before 12
rules comes out and we'll talk about
that book in a little bit more detail
okay in advance coffee awesome and thank
you for coming on obviously but more
important thanks for being out there
thanks for spreading a positive message
again very aligned with what I say
you're coming at people from a different
angle than I come from but that message
I think is gonna make people better
which in turn as you just said is gonna
make the world a better place and I know
I know that you are working hard to make
this happen and I truly appreciate the
fact that you are doing that so it
doesn't doesn't seem like there's
anything better to do that's kind of it
seems like a basic truth doesn't it it's
like there are things that aren't so
good we could probably fix most of them
so like what you got something better to
do than that doesn't seem like it let's
at least have a good shot at it
Yeah right exactly exactly and to the
people that make this podcast possible
and that is the soldiers sailors airmen
and Marines on the front lines who
protect our right to free speech those
folks that are living out the archetype
of the hero they're out there fighting
the dragon and killing the snakes and
protecting us from evil
thanks to all you servicemen and women
for protecting us and to police and law
enforcement firefighters paramedics and
other first responders thank you for
keeping us safe on the homefront and to
everyone else that is listening remember
this there is evil in the world there
are snakes and there are dragons and
there are depraved human beings and
pathologies that can rip you apart but
there is also your world that you
control and you have the ability to
stand up against evil and against those
snakes in your own way
and make your world a better place so
stand up and get after it
so until next time this is dr. Jordan
Peterson and echo and Jocko